so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello guys welcome to the dragon ball
fighterz tenkaichi online challenge
masters japan edition
tyrant and c4 on the mic here to bring
you guys this exciting top eight bracket
what is going on bro how you been i've
been alright man enjoying a lot of
dragon ball especially this weekend and
it's
so much more to come right for all the
regions um
can't wait to get some uh
dragon ball from asia it feels like it's
been a while since since i've seen some
yeah it's going to be 250 now we've got
some great plays in the fractal today
guys we're going to be running that down
very very shortly but thank you so much
for joining us here as the dragon ball
fighters world championship rolls on man
we've got some uh more exciting events
man it feels like every week we've got
something awesome to look forward to uh
in terms of the high level dragon ball
fighterz action from all around the
globe um of course we are going to be
rolling on into the regional finals in
december um but before we get there
we've got the online phase to get
through first before we get to the duty
offline games we've got these online ggs
to enjoy first and see who uh who's
gonna earn their place you know um we've
seen some of the invited players already
out there on the bambomco esports
twitter account but um yeah we're gonna
be getting some of our online heroes uh
qualified as well so yeah it's going to
be cool already
yeah i can't wait man like especially
it feels like it's been such a while so
obviously because of the situation on
the world
to see some like high-level players
especially now with invitationals
i think it's some of the dream matches
that we couldn't have seen because of
like offline kind of being stopped for a
while
all the stories from before about some
of the n a players versus eu and e
versus jp like i can't wait to see all
that stuff again man
especially because it feels like it's
been so many patches ago it's gonna be
like a completely different game yeah
totally different game i know man like
we saw that at the um
obviously you know
big offline uh uh events event in paris
the usa vs france event that was so cool
to see you know some of these matchups
again and it really is a different game
offline and it's just beautiful to watch
um but we're going to be getting to get
into that in a few months time before
that guys it's all about the tenkaichi
online challenge here and i can see some
of the community events i've been
rolling on it's been really cool to see
um you guys out there doing your thing
all the to's holding it down um and uh
some of our players um in the scene
already earning points towards the um
tenkaichi online challenge so that's
really really cool
um but man we've got some great players
coming up here from japan man
that the home of dragon ball you know
these th
it's really really yeah it's really
really cool to see it man like it's
and i'm looking forward to seeing some
of these ggs now we've got some
interesting players um some good
character variety i believe as well so
should be a great watch for you guys at
home
yeah it was the exclamation mark bracket
in the chat that should get the break up
for you guys so you can see the top
eight straight to the action right i
know normally tildens you see from like
pool playing stuff but straight into the
top eight
here we go bracket on screen for our
winner's side
we have uh
nicody i'm sorry for butchering any of
these names
tell me in chat
you come on man use your inner weave
come on bro
that's his uh
you know
let it rip like that but yeah that
should be a great one for sure um
a lot of these players i'm not even sure
about man like i i i can't say you know
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna say i've
seen every single one of these players
playing i've studied all their gameplay
because a lot of them i'm i'm not
familiar with you know um but yeah that
will be the first game we've got on
stream guys on wonders side uh kuzumots
versus nick jose dropping down there
again winner semi side uh pepe versus um
pot angel 16
is a very strong hits player um i've
definitely seen some footage of him in
the past and then um the other side as
well so uh
is that's that's verde so you guys
know about that um exciting
that is um that one there but um he
signed up on smashy g with his like with
the actual um japanese characters so
that's a direct translation so that is
verdane um going up against moja um in
the uh the final game of uh round one so
yeah that's our first that's our lineup
of matches there guys should be
interesting right yeah like you said uh
verdane is definitely one of the members
one of the names i remember from from
way back i remember
before there was a meta and people
thought they could pick any character
they wanted to uh all big buddies uh
they used to play like zebra only cell
uh i remember seeing him getting
snapchats like damn uh
one day hopefully a patch will bless you
to play your big body team and it did
happen i just didn't know if he was
playing the same team so it'll be
interesting to see if he's stuck with a
z broly in the cell and stuff uh
should be cool to see and yeah like you
said some of the other players i'm not
not very aware of but it'd be
interesting you know coming from
jp to get this viral tournament they
have to be good right so we've got to be
in for a pretty good showcase i reckon
absolutely guys it should be a great one
for sure um
yeah one moment guys just go you have
some uh audio stuff going on here but
yeah it should be great man i'm really
hyped for this um
we should be getting the action up for
you guys very very soon
please uh bear with us while we uh get
the ggs on the way because we aren't
good for hunger for some games just like
you guys it's uh it's like uh you know
half three a.m here in the uk so i am
ready
and taught some action i want some ggs
man watch the dragon ball and wake me up
a bit yeah definitely man uh i feel the
same way i've got the energy drinks and
all that ready for
for the games ahead but i know the
matches will definitely
get us wild up as well so
yeah like i said i think it's really
interesting i think like he was talking
about earlier with the uh n a versus
france
the the region that bringing their type
of gameplay and they're sort of met up
to the table
uh like we keep saying i've just not
seen
jp play in such a long time i'm i'm
interested to see what their fault of
this patch
right we will see
you know tearless and stuff on twitter
and they vary from players to play out i
want to see the region here this i want
to see what
uh they think is strong
since the last patch uh and obviously
that's going to be presented through
their teams because you know
they always play the stuff that strong
they might have one or two characters
that they really really like but they
have to to stay on top and like i said
be this far in the tournament they're
gonna have to kind of play the meta and
what works
in their region so yeah i definitely
want to see that
man it's going to be interesting for
sure and before you say it man it's all
about the meta and stuff like that right
we want to see um how the uh the japan
scene has been you know moving around uh
the board with this version of the game
because
it's a very different patch man this is
a completely different patch and japan
have always been the best at really just
moving from meta to meta and dragon ball
fighters and really just taking
advantage of what that version of the
game has to offer i think um
with maybe the big exception of the most
recent season uh the one before this one
like they before that they were just me
you know really taking advantage of
everything i think
i think kazunoko was was the prime
example of really just adapting to the
meta for the last version of the game
like now for the you know national
championship we saw him really just
embrace the game um
uh for for what it was with that you
know that season three game play um so
i'm looking forward to see how the japan
players have really just stepped things
up here with this version of the game of
all the different changes um that we've
seen um bandai namco implement in this
one so yeah should be good yeah i really
i feel maybe because i've been uh
susceptible to it a lot whether they're
gonna go for the mix heavy play style
that you see a lot of n a play so the
sort of uh set play
get someone to block 50 50 them to death
i want to see if they adopt that or kind
of the europe scene where it's kind of a
bit more okay we might have mixed but
we've got the fluid motion we've got the
movement we've got the assists that
cover the screen and then frame trap you
uh i know previously they've gone more
for the lockdown especially like he said
with kazunako from the beginning right
he was locked down with the amateur
assist mix you up when goten was really
strong he went to go tanks we even saw
people like finrich uh pick up that
character as well
and i mean
i remember back in the day where they
were like well you kind of need boo
assist to open up goichi so everyone
went like yep 50 50. that's the name of
the game that's what my team is going to
be a role for around but i think
definitely uh france is the bigger
proprietor about playing neutral right
and eu has always kind of done that
i i just don't i don't know i don't know
are we going to see goji uh uh shj4
is that is that in their region or
or is he kind of a gimmick because he
doesn't have a beat he's got no neutral
remember right yeah exactly yeah
it's going to be interesting to see what
they
how they which teams they play um i'm
looking forward to seeing that for sure
i know i know a couple of the characters
are we going to be seeing today but um
overall man i have no idea what the
general consensus is going to be in
terms of like team composition and stuff
like that so um yeah man like i i'm kind
of uh as
in the dark as a lot of you guys are you
know i'm not sure what we're gonna see
in terms of uh overall gameplay and
stuff like that from the japan online
side of things
but yeah it should be interesting for
sure man i'm really looking forward to
seeing the first game get underway we
are waiting guys like um
we're just getting the plays in the
lobby and stuff like that here
but um yeah man it's going to be a good
one for sure the world championship
rolls on guys
[Music]
i can see some of you guys in the chat
here joining us should we should be fun
we're having fun in there i know my mic
sounds a bit messed up by now but we're
going to get started don't worry we're
going to get it fixed
and there we go so there we go guys if
you want to break down this uh little uh
run down here so you thought that'd be
fantastic bro yeah so uh september and
november this is gonna be the ten catchy
online challenges uh kind of the season
of uh world championship that we're in
right now right uh people gathering up
points to get into the regional finals
in december that will be offline and
then obviously early 2022 will be the
finals the best of the best the creme de
la creme all the finalists and people
have qualified it's gonna be so good
yeah it's gonna be absolutely insane
like
i know it's starting off online
but you're still picking the best
players and we've got the invitation
also when it comes to the regional
finals and then the finals it's going to
be
the best of the best right the people
that have grinded out and everyone's
kind of on a even footing because
the the new patch like we said has
changed it so much
it's it's going to be
really i don't think anyone really knows
you might be able to say a player that's
going to get there but what they're
going to bring to the table can't really
tell because things are changing not so
drastically and yeah
i i don't know and again i keep going
back to the 5v5 i think that was a very
big demonstration of the two play styles
and where they can work and where they
can't so yes yeah
yeah absolutely man uh it was it was a
really big eye opener for a lot of
people you know a lot of a lot of us
included you know we got to see wow this
is the levels right now this is kind of
what we need to be uh looking at in
terms of this this current season of the
game in terms of meta and stuff like
that so yeah really really exciting
stuff man french players just moving
forward and of course we saw a few words
on twitter there as well the um
the uh yeah you go ichi you know you
awaken the the beasts
jiren awoke from his slumber you know
he's out here now
but yeah here is the the online
challenge breakdown guys just to keep
you guys updated um
in what is uh gonna be happening here
with the online series so of course the
the uh we do have two different versions
of the online tournaments here guys
we've got the tenkaichi online challenge
which is the community round events and
then of course we have the official band
on amco events which is the tenkaichi
online master challenge and of course
those master events will net you more
points um and it's for example what
we're doing here today we've already ran
a couple of these tournaments the uh
officially ran events
um with the big boy points on the line
and that's what we're doing today
so
we're going to be seeing some of that
guys hopefully my mic sounds a little
bit better now uh you can see the points
breakdown on the screen as well
for uh for example what we're doing
today is the one you see on the left
there 200 points um for first place
um and then moving down the board there
all the way down to 17 if you still get
points
and then of course depends on how many
entrants your
community tournaments get will depend on
how many points will be distributed so
yeah the dojo system in place here for
the dragon ball fighters
online uh tenkaichi challenge and yeah
you can see the platform right there
it's both guys pc and ps4 um will be the
preferred platforms um for the events
should be good
yeah i think uh
here we go like with the regions i was
gonna talk about right area one japan
area two europe and that's been broken
up to four you're at one two three four
as you see on the screen right there
north america west is area six areas
arena sorry arena seven north america
east then we've got brazil mexico
australia and the middle east bringing
in the last four arenas i think uh
what he was talking about obviously the
difference between the ten catches and
the master ones right the community ones
the the importance of coming in i feel
first and second when it comes to the
master events can put you so far ahead
because obviously 200 points for first
150 you can grind the community
tournaments 10 catches and and try to
make up those uh
points to catch up but the
the big gap you get from coming in first
in the master series does give you such
a good leg up against the rest of the
competition
uh yeah you can't put so much there's so
much importance in these master series
when it comes to points uh i think
people do need to remember that because
it's not also guaranteed yeah but you
basically have to go on vacation for the
rest of the two months and not enter
anything
to lose your spot right yeah for sure
for sure it definitely puts you ahead of
the competition by a big stretch but
these will be the regional finals guys
this is where it gets offline okay so
starting on the december's going to be a
busy month man we're going to get those
early christmas presents right there
because on the 4th and 5th of december
that's the regional finals for europe
that's where we decide um which european
players are going to be moving on to the
uh the world finals and then of course
on the 11th and 12th of december will be
the usa side of things same thing but
with the us players the invited players
and the qualified online players and an
exact same for the japan side on the
18th 19th december so man december is
going to be a busy month in terms of
offline dragon ball fighters man it's
going to be so so good
yeah i was uh gonna have to cancel
behind the tree too much dragon ball to
watch that's gonna have to go on the
back burner
yeah here we go world championship
regional finals 12 players eight invite
players uh we've been seeing those go up
on twitter like uh tyron mentioned
earlier yeah plus four splotch
qualifiers from the catchy from the ten
catchy online challenges so this is why
you have to be on every weekend so far
through this month to catch out the
people that are getting the big big
points from the master series uh then he
goes into a round-robin format and here
we go with the regional final breakdown
the top four go from regional finals to
the shin grand finals later on early on
sorry in 2022
yeah it's actually going to be sick guys
and you can you can follow along with
the um
with the if you want to check out the
points guys you can check out the dragon
ball fighterz esports portal which we're
going to talk about in a moment but guys
this is where how the points uh we're
going to break down yeah the east portal
is open but you just saw on the screen
if we go back to the um
yes that's perfect yeah so this is how
it's going to work guys so the top four
from the europe um
uh
from from the leaderboards we'll move on
to the regional finals uh the top two
from each east and west leaderboard for
the us will advance on to the uh
regional finals there
the japan top four from the leaderboards
will go into there as well in the japan
side of things and then of course we
have these fast track uh tournaments so
uh so you know mexico australia um
brazil and then middle east africa
are going to have those tournaments and
those ones will be fast tracked to the
world championship final as well as top
four from europe usa and japan so man
that's how we're going to get our top
16. um and that finals are going to be
taking place in early 2020 which is
really really exciting stuff
yeah and again like you said uh to apply
it for to's as well go to the portal so
you can make sure that your community
your local scene even though it's online
can get some points to try and get into
the regionals
exactly yeah you want to be up there man
representing your region uh and it's
going to be it's going to be so cool to
you know
i mean this is really exciting as it is
we've got these online tournaments we're
seeing who is uh you know really
grinding the game and just exploring the
current patch and things like that uh
we're gonna see who is gonna take those
skills from the online environment um to
join our invited players for the
regional finals and that's just where
it's really going to go down and we can
have some real surprises come through
you never know especially when it comes
to what what we have to to show today c4
with the the japan uh masters event man
i'm willing to bet some of these guys
are going to be ridiculous man because
we had we had some serious names in the
bracket i didn't even make top eight bro
aqua didn't even make top eight he's he
was in there yeah man like it was it was
it would have been looking like a rough
bracket but we're gonna get straight in
guys we've got kuzumasu vs nekoze let's
get our first game of the day
okay okay oh well let me get the uh the
tyrant energy kuzamotsu yeah let's see
let's go let's go okay
i'm seeing the forbidden one i'm seeing
the nerfed one on the screen right now
what's going on i thought it was trash i
thought it was a write-off man i thought
it was right off and he's on point as
well this is this is what i think uh
really shows goatens is a potential yeah
is when he's on point because
i've seen a lot of ignorant stuff in
this game
round start beyblade seems almost
unstoppable
yeah
oh we've got classy we don't do that we
don't do that clearly
okay there we go right here
starting things off an interesting uh
team off the bat immediately this is
what i was talking about when it comes
to interesting teams in that those
competitions guys because you're not
making it work here let's let's find out
we've got oh my goodness it doesn't
matter 2h
you can definitely see it's not 3am over
there man he was ready he was he was
woke can't like that that was a 60 h
yeah he comes 21 though
that was that was not a 3 a.m uh
all right
boom there we go we are knocked down
time here who's in what's right now
safe jump
okay yeah man all the staggers 21 bro
everyone's worst nightmare oh avoids the
grab
reflects the super dash there oh my
goodness opened up there by the dr here
we go android 21
getting that work now
man enough i've seen this
this is some weird teams for japan boy i
normally i'm used to seeing like adult
gohan like kid buu
you know like uh the season two teams
i'm i'm definitely with you i think like
the the bardot kid boo kind of it's like
a nice throwback but the golgi are
that's just like i like this character
you hardly ever see go cheetah blue
especially in these big tournament
scenarios man
for sure yeah
that was so sick
okay
here we go
good stuff right now for nekozei should
be able to get this kill
nice there we go
oh the assist in there as well oh my all
right okay look we're gonna spend three
bars here to get that kill
android 21 is out of picture and i say i
have to say man looking at kuzumotsu's
team i feel like that is the main
character you want to be killing as soon
as possible because 21 is a terror
doesn't matter where she is on the team
man
she's a nightmare
yeah i agree but got the two oh my gosh
i've gotta say got the two kids in but
technically it's three but one of them's
going down right now yeah right yeah
yeah this is gonna be nice right here
for a four necklace they should be able
to finish the combo er knock down level
three on the way yep there it is
yeah it makes sense get the hard knock
down probably won't see a level five
here i mean it would be cool but ah no
need for it i'd love to see it man like
but yeah we're not going to be seeing
that just yet okay spark up there from
fujimotsu here we go this is a chance to
fight back now goes to the other side
low
all right reflects out
to him attempt oh open the water combo
oh no it doesn't matter where you're
from bro japan they're still going to
use
combos man mash out there and that's
going to be a dead character team gohan
so much damage
yeah and i know you're talking about
location but also gogia did a two minute
loss to it like i don't think anything
can beat that bad unless it's a 2h like
that button is literally a heat-seeking
missile ain't it
okay
man nick jose right now oh no no no oh
my goodness the two edges have been on
point bro
not three a.m man can't be doing those
can't be doing those as we get kid
getting the level three
got to knock down bardock assist ready
and willing to be thrown at any second
doesn't need it
[Music]
tournament dragon rush man online no
one's taking those here we go team gohan
in now kusumotsu's final character and
remember guys it's two out of three
until uh we get to the finals here so
could be a bad look right now nekoze
will be able to close this out just has
to finish his plate right now
there we go
first guys
yeah clutching out with that you know
the close range super dash has it's
always been a very potent thing in
dragon ball right just
the last thing you're expecting you
always especially like kid boot because
he's got some insane on the air and in
the ground and then they just do a super
dash you try to react you have to delay
a little bit because it's start-up on it
and when it's that close to your face
it's it's very like
nerve-sharing to be like i don't know
what to do and you you you shake you
literally shake because you're like do i
back dash to try and make it like to get
some space so i can react uh yeah and
yeah it all goes downhill real quick
when when you apply so much pressure and
you stay really close to someone and
like i said it's kid boot you're always
scared of being close to you man it's
terrifying yeah kid buu is a character
that has just never he doesn't know what
being lotus feels like he's always been
up there or they've even tried to nerf
this guy yeah still ridiculous man you
can't stop kid boo he's just so strong
um great tool set great assists just an
all-round strong character man and you
know
really really good stuff um here we go
going straight in here
second game of the set
let's get it
okay man we didn't get to see much of
gotenks in the last game did we really
yeah no he got that that early 2 h but
right now he gives a hit
nice
let's see i mean he got here to win his
semis for a reason you know
okay nice they're using that neutral
jump on the double jump to keep that
good spacing for the ghosts and now he's
gonna get an extension here
ghost assist one more left
no okay it went away all right but there
we go gets another set up going on
yeah it doesn't look to use it spark to
get away from the uh the ghost
and that's the thing man i mean we've
talked about how gotenks was like
directly nerfed right they nerfed some
of his damage options and it was kind of
religious but still
um
oh wow
guarantee the kill on bardock i like it
that's real sick yeah he's not going to
need any uh halloween
how do we mix ups all right just going
to go get the kill
yeah i mean it's it's spooky month right
now it's october
uh is going to be a clean kill right
there for kuzumatsu but yeah so we
talked about how gotenks was you know he
was he was one of the only nerf
characters in the game right but
bro ghost okie
is ridiculous you can have the damage on
it it's still super potent man it's
going to get you to hit you know you've
got four assists there essentially to
help open up your opponent
literally and i think we're going to see
it again right here we go october oaky
he's deleted right
yeah
bro he's dead man i'm telling you like
this character is just he hits too hard
dynamite though kick oh all right
that was sick
oh yeah tohan level one does insane
damage and again
sending out
the ghosts go tanks on a tear-up so this
is why they're in winner's side right i
see it now i see it yeah man this this
this is one of those teams that bro once
it starts going
you might as well give up like it just
feels like it goes downhill for you so
quickly you know what i mean
absolutely can you compare this to the
first game
yeah complete shift and here we go
october time again
really
oh my goodness guys that was ridiculous
and you can really see how he has fully
built his team around with this go tanks
because it looks like any hit you're in
the corner it's just ghosts all day
indeed indeed but the classic does stop
the rampage of gotenks reflect into 2m
the kid boo classic here we go
talk to him shout the kids kid boo
it's
oh what's your dome piece opened up
that's gonna be a dead go tanks okay
here we go kid boo bruh this ghostly
looking kimboo you want revenge
yeah all
hey right my goodness super dash
oh god here we go
it's just cool oh man because he wants
to uh
really implemented that
that neutral um those neutral assist
calls and bruv he just dp through he
said i don't care about trick or treat
or not i don't want no candy okay here
we go
dragon rush
yeah i don't think he's dead though
yeah no he's not dead
got to get this hard knock down though
uh no spark on the table so he's gonna
have to be pretty honest on his block
here
or not okay
blue combos yeah all right
yeah yeah
aqua but they do the same amount of
damage and this is the scary part right
okay nicosia's just made the the
comeback
potentially oh no way
oh my goodness that 3m
okay here we go
awesome wow taking a risk there with
that after the two edges we've seen okay
roll
that vanish right at the end
maybe even a panic but it paid off
because bro jose was mounting that
comeback i was seeing some
some down the gameplay was going
downhill for after i swear after gotenks
dies it looks like kuzumotsu's game plan
it can it can start to dwindle um
but you know able to hold it together
there at the end takes it and we're
going 1-1 here one more game guys to go
let's see who advances onto the winner's
finals
yeah i mean yeah like you said that
gotenk seems to be like the glue the key
to uh to the team the the whole
synergy does feel like it's revolved
around gotenks even though the
individual characters are so strong
right 121 are very strong characters on
their own uh but you do tend to see them
more in the point position right yes but
we've opted to go with go take some
point and it makes sense because we've
seen the strength of that team right
because goten gets that hit he hits you
with october halloween stuff and you
lose the character if you guess
wrong once yeah and he i feel like
gotenk is a good character to have on
point actually you know we don't usually
see that because you know he's all of
his assists are so good and you know
switching into the ghost and stuff is
great but
um i feel like
you know implementing this neutral style
of dragon ball fighters now you know
just flying around the screen using
gotenk's movement options calling the
assists and just converting off hits
like that is just so good like
at the end of the day look what he's
getting from this boom straight into the
ghost okay set it up
that's that's just
really really prone gameplay man that
can be so scary to deal with because
look we've got so much to think about
yeah too many layers for for one bar
you're in a world of her and
it's the yes one more time trick or
treat
he didn't win eva no treats yeah and
this this is how things went last time
nekoze used that spark unfortunately
last time he didn't get the hit but this
game he does and this could be the
difference maker c4 let's find out
yep go straight to kid through the
character that's done a lot of work
during this set
because
what's he going to do for the okie oh
wow and this time it's kuzumasu that
will spark up trying to get that hit
here on kid boo and he does so goes
behind with it and let's go gonna get
himself some good damage oh my goodness
he's got those all right i see you
kuzuma yeah i love to see chad cancels i
think they look super cool yeah man
they're all right
sorry
you want to talk about oaky this is some
of the best movie in the game coming up
right now
oh
of people's uh team building there like
the team construction having a dp and
being able to do super dash dp assist so
much hits done really oh
what bro
that that's crazy to block and of course
necklace i'm not blocking it guys we all
got hit there kuzumatsu 21.
bro i opened up see assist i see you
and that's on both sides as well right
the css kid boot
and go text
accessible beams into full combos as we
see gogeta getting his level three
trying to claw it back right against the
uh the three member team
is it mutso doesn't take the dragon rush
that's unfortunate
yeah kuzumasu was focused on blocking
but guess what you can't block dragon
rush that's gonna do it right there here
we go
team gohan in now the super saiyan 2
let's go
very even life oh my goodness dragon
rash
okay
right now it's a bad look for neko's a
gonna go into the father son come home
let's see what the oaky's gonna be
he did he got baited out right
into level one into the ghosts again and
that's gonna get the kill on gogeta blue
final character coming in for nekoze
right now and it's that kid boot
man kid boo it's whole home go tanks
it's this tiny season out here man yeah
your man season small body games oh what
a jungle conversion though that was
because he was airborne on the beam
yeah
oh
but is that success got into trouble
right now okay oh my goodness
bro if this was uh season three you
remember when the hands were broken that
was this might be dead but no
not enough
yeah oh wow bad dash to him he jumps
away from the deal
yo he just jumped out the command grab
that was that that was yeah that was a
street fighter punish boy he just held
up back and then punished the command
punished the dr like it was a command
grab from zangief that's gonna do it
right great play right there uh from our
go tanks specialist kuzumotsu with a
unique team advancing into the winners
finals you love to see it man these
different teams doing work is always a
pleasure to see and uh
i i love this team strategy honestly it
feels really really uh snowball effect
you know goten gets the hit using those
great assists with the insane done
and then you know you're guessing for
your life against four ghosts in the
corner it's never fun
never it's never been funny none of the
seasons and it's something it's
interesting right because we've said
this and i know you was a big player of
you know the gotenk stuff right back in
the day yeah the thing is like when you
think about it now there's not that many
gotenks players in uh na or eu
especially on point especially on point
uh i guess unlike kid buu go tanks does
feel nurse eventually right yeah yeah
yeah exactly i mean
uh to be honest with you i still feel
like grotesque is a capable character
but at the end of the day he is one of
the only characters in the game that
that received direct nerfs not just from
the game system like his actual some of
his tool set was directly you know
damage decrease and you know options
somewhat limited like well a bit more
limited now but he still has like
you know
even after the damage now if he still
still does some of the highest damage in
the game yeah the ghost okie is still
some of the best you know knock down
pressure in the game as well
uh you know good assists and let's not
forget some of the system mechanic
changes also helped gotenks like the z
change now during the specials that is
great because you know you get the um
the die die missiles you can do switch
into pretty much anything you want
dragon rush whatever you want to do so
we saw it in that set actually so yeah
man i feel like kuzumotsu has pieced
together a great team here it's about
getting the hit in neutral using those
insane assists and gotenks's movement
options and then just setting up the
ghost and having fun essentially
yeah yeah i'd love to see it and i i
hope oh well we're definitely going to
see that more in this top 8 i want to
see what uh what else he's got to bring
to the table because i know there's a
lot of tricks up of gotenk's sleeve and
with the damage and assist he's got in
the background right with tolhan he must
have some real clean like tods that
we're not expecting to see
but
we've got our next match who we got
it's going to be uh pepe versus
potential so
let's see how this one unfolds because
we're seeing ui goku right now this
character guys this character just a
beast and we've got some more goji to
blue all right let's go
we have a
some good postures some very tall
characters on screen that's all i'll
have to see man yeah that pose boy here
we go but man another unique team i'm
seeing go tanks again here from pepe
android 17.
we've got um
wow
some unique lineups here and we've got
the online special team from potential
bro that is the that is the awesome
assist online warrior team that you're
scared of seeing him ranked right there
yeah it's like
it seems like they've just seen uh
you know the canon tier list that's the
canon
that's real sick this is my favorite
characters i'm going to make it work
but like you said they have so much
damage one hit and you'll know about it
not being fake
[Music]
right there the man with the ultra
instinct and of course android 17 coming
in to help him out and all that spark
time getting wasted on potential side
sparks up to guarantee the kill there we
go yeah he's going to go straight into
super
ghost and in angular 17 we'll get the
kill here great stuff there from pepe
good start yeah and i don't think we
really touched upon how unique pepe
steve is right 17 go tents uh
yeah that's that's very different for
any region for any reason that's
something oh that's a thing okay
universe uh survival art featuring go
tanks here
okay let's see here goes back i have to
block this now
vegeto oh opened up the wreckers and
that's your boy doing work c4 i know you
are a bit of a 17 uh a proficient player
yourself so i'm sure you're loving that
this action right now i i fully yeah man
i've got time for the uh the monster
island ranger himself man look here look
at the work he did just off of record
this guy
i mean
is level two gonna kill here
off the wall
yeah
i didn't believe man
oh my god the damage is gonna be crazy
bro this is this was auto combo second
hit
yeah i know you said you didn't believe
but someone did someone clearly believed
that when oh you know the first whiff on
the l that was spacing for the second
one that's all that was it was it was
offensive spacing yeah it was the first
light was to get him out the corner and
the second one was to get the punishment
yeah oh my god oh bro
he's made that two h like a flash kick
that was insane
okay backing off now there we go the
assist in there dp into the super
super close kamikaze attack
gets a tech away in the air
oh no there was a gap there was a gap
right there he did not vanish
immediately so that of course will be
punished
potential right now just going to work
oh no what happened
don't even meant to do that
oh no
hey assist man working out i mean los
angeles 17 now records them down to the
ground should be able to close this out
with a single bar spend yes he will okay
boom
let's go final character for potential
yeah 17 closing out with the barrier
explosion there vegeta on his own
without spark i mean he does a lot of
damage but
we might see it right now speaking of
yeah limit break vegito is a bit of a
monster i'm not gonna lie and he's gonna
be able to get pressure on this he has
barf he wants to vanish or you can just
dash up whatever he wants to do let's
find out yeah vanish
oh my goodness
someone has been watching their french
players
a ghetto
they've been watching it
yo techies take us for sharing thank you
for sharing for sure for sure
oh my goodness
oh scary stuff
okay
don't count oh wait
okay get himself out of danger right
there with the guard cancel vanish oh
no no no no no
that's gonna be it right there pepe gets
there here and with that ultra instant
goku gonna be able to get the theme get
the kill
right but you could you could just see
right there how scary hank of anchor
vegito can be man rounds start 5m
he just pressures you gets a straight
hit and then all of a sudden
your life is just getting destroyed you
know
you're getting battered so
great play um from pepe to start things
off there yeah he's a he's been a
stagger monster for a long time right
and then they just gave him
more uh more utility on his normals
right just being able to start from
forever right exactly like id uh h into
5m doesn't whiff anymore just straight
up it can't miss like and that's it
feels like a quality of life change but
it makes the difference right because it
makes him consistent so you might not
have much when it comes to mix even
though you know sss same side sword is
definitely mixed don't let anyone tell
you different
it might hit mid but it's definitely a
mix but when he does have that grand uh
pressure going on you don't have to
worry about things missing and spirit
fingers to lock you down uh 5s
it is
it seems in your head and in t-mode like
i just have to crouch block and react to
6m it's fine but in the moment it's not
that easy yeah it's really not easy at
all man like we all talk about oh man
vegeta he just you can't high-low you
just chill and block it but yeah like
you know
we all know at this point it's not a
meme anymore we know how how potent
vegito can be um you know we've seen it
even in the offline environment france
just absolutely doing damage with this
team uh with this character rather so
let's find out how things go here is
pepe gonna get another double his
potential gonna do work here with the uh
cannon tearless team
yeah right now did get hit was it ready
for the confirmed this time he is though
ex wreckers
delayed it
real nice
decent damage as well if you think about
it that's crazy
it is it is not 3am in japan it's so
it's not these guys are so ready with
those anti-airs man like
i would be scared to ied let alone super
dash if they're too hated stuff like
that that's crazy scary scary okay
there we go volleyball attack knocked
down boom
good eighty percent for potentials go gf
life coming off
yeah hey
whoa
whoa what happened there i think he
actually tried two ways it could be
wrong but
yeah it may be maybe
i think there was a reach up there
there's definitely a timeline where he
re-jumps off of that right
yeah he used um that was really dope oh
no and the 2m hitting this is going to
be massive damage and also getting a lot
of bar there with that sparking meter
game
here we go
into level three
yeah ah
the combos pepe is pulling off bro
they're doing a good 80 each time and
they'll tell you what that really does
put things in your favor if you think
about it in terms of uh odds when it
comes to dishing out damage that was
kind of crazy
yeah i think that's definitely the name
of the game especially with these two
teams right it's like okay
wow the two h's and that's and this is
one of the strong things about uh 17
that a lot of characters used to have
back in the day getting damage of the
two hate without assists
yes
remember like 16 used to have it 21
still has it right just doing 2h bring
you back down in some way or form uh
jiren has it now as well with his 2h and
17 just rips of damage if he ever too
hated you yeah he does a lot now they
they really did
help him out in the in that department
man okay
oh my goodness look at that the assist
working out
as always bro looking like season three
right here oh he tried it no no no no no
panic button right there was hit
potential but that means pepe's eyes lit
up here when he's gonna get the kill
yeah android 17 man he didn't lose a
character there pepe looking ridiculous
he's gonna advance on to the winner's
final play against kuzumatsu
the go tanks yo go tanks mirrors in
winners finals what's going on
he said this at the beginning right
we're an asian now like we don't know
what that matter is but yeah i i cannot
remember the last time i saw two go
tanks in grand valley cannot
yeah man like that is that is crazy man
like you would have thought we would see
in the previous season of the game man
so many people dropped gotenk so many
people thought that it was a write-off
for him
that we didn't expect to see him here
like
that's kind of crazy uh
really impressive stuff here from uh
from from pepe
i'm liking this and again these unique
teams bro like
ui 17 go tanks that's
not a team i expected to see here in the
top 8 masters event man not at all not
at all like a band like junanago so like
in in france we've seen people pick up
17 mostly for his assist and stuff but
i think here was a demonstration of how
strong he is as a as a point character
even though he wasn't put on point for
the team
but the the damage he brings and from
the two haters that we saw multiple
times right yeah his uniqueness uh with
his uh combo extensions yeah i think i
like
almost unrivaled right just the ability
to take you anywhere on the screen be
able to bring you down and get an easy
long grinder to confirm and build a ton
of bar while he's doing it uh yeah just
just insane a really good display of 17
and such a unique team like you're
saying something i know i've not been
exposed to that much so i'm i'm loving
what i'm seeing yeah for sure man and
one of the things that we need to speak
about when it comes to android 17 is is
the meter game this guy gets man like
especially with this whenever this guy
activates spark bro this guy is getting
like a ton of meter for his team and for
a team that includes characters like you
know go tanks you you want a ghost okay
non-stop uh ui you want those level twos
non-stop as well like
it is a really really good um
team composure there man i'm looking
forward to seeing how pepe does against
kuzumasu in the winners finals because
that should be a fantastic match but um
that's it for the winners side for now
guys we're dropping down to the losers
bracket we've got some great games on
the way um we're gonna see some ikon i
know you guys i know like hit is a
character that a lot of you viewers like
watching and and econ is one of the
stronger hits in the entire world man um
using uh using the character
out of japan you know it's a region that
we don't usually see a lot of hit you
know tachikawa has rocked the hit before
out of that region but cohen is
definitely someone that's been putting
in the work with him so i'm looking
forward to seeing that match and then
later on we're going to be seeing uh
verdain versus moja
verdane is of course the zebrali tech
monster uh he's a beast man he's been
putting in that work for a long time so
that should be fun
uh but yeah man we've got some more
great matches on the way so let's go
i'm ready for it
yeah yeah losers you know this is where
people wear their backs against the wall
right they can't afford to lose so
they're gonna throw everything at their
opponent because uh you know taking a
nail is not an option anymore so
the blades you said about uh like hit
mastery zidane uh the danger not today
but then bringing the uh the big buddies
hopefully he's still playing big buddies
because he played him in a in a timeline
where he wasn't favorable yes exactly
now
now he's kind of had uh taking the
shackles off of his characters so when
when he says dragon rushed he could
still play the game potentially because
back in the day
he got dragon rush and putting down the
stick was a favorable option sometimes
yeah
he definitely got a like in previous
versions of the game brother i feel like
playing z broly was like a death
sentence man like it was
it was not good like like any big
character was was not favorable the end
of the day because you know the
the the fuzzy guards were were flying
like it wasn't fun yeah
yeah but uh if i let's go i think i can
hear the match ready to start so we're
gonna get into it momentarily guys but
thank you all so much for joining us
here uh wherever whatever time it is
where you're at right now it's currently
demon hours here in the uk bro it's like
4 a.m and that but we are out here to
enjoy some dragon ball we're ready
fellas let's get it colin this is fran
out
let's see
hours bro that's definitely demon time
but uh yeah
speaking of broly
being possible yes the imposter we've
got the legendary uh
legendary super saiyan from universe 6
guys let's go
oh
and we've got a ginyu ginyu kid boo and
you i i'm telling you sometimes the
mayor is pick two strong characters and
then pick your favorite maybe uh
maybe franco is the he's a guy like me i
i think ginny's design is cool i think
you have to be super big brain for your
brain to be seen outside of your head
bruv it's it's real
real wrinkly hours on that on that
forehead right now look at this
the bulging head that is just the big
brain you need to play this character
man i'm telling you
all opened up
yeah we might not see much of uh giving
you this match this is going to be a
grip of damage to assist
oh no not to assist only one
oh is that has that hit c right that's
dead
insane let's go man can you talk about
ginyu we didn't even get to see the guy
toxentai got rinsed
yeah that's uh that's what five
characters down i'm left with
it's a strong duo right oh yeah this is
this is definitely a strong team for
sure um
wow
right there these guys are on it with
the anti-airs man like the fundamentals
are looking oh no drop the combo though
what happened
yeah like you said the fundamentals are
there but uh
the combos
but it's okay long as you can get the
hit
one more time oh my goodness
i said i've gotta go faster he just
zooms up his way in there spent two bars
well tenkaichi online challenge man he's
online being the key word he's gonna
lose his side man
yeah correct right there on the auto
combo all right bring it into the corner
now oh spark up for me
what is
i i feel like i'm watching army back in
the day man this actually was like an
episode of dragon ball
is
both those level ones without the
follow-ups are very weak oh my goodness
what a complaint
kefla gonna go to work he should be able
to switch out into a different character
level three yep there it is
that
was so demonic like doing the dash and
then calling your dp assist and not
knowing what side it's on hitting me
every time oh wow he actually got the
hit but
then went for the dr didn't believe i
guess but there we go
oh now
that's really
how the game is we've seen being played
for a lot of different reasons right now
um just using your movement options and
then using these great assists the
assists are fast have good hitboxes good
hits done um to just convert your damage
and you know
take down your opponent's life bar just
like we're seeing right here yep yep
hundred percent and and again like
it's just clicked for me another goji a
blue and not an ssj4
yeah that's so true
yeah we're not seeing much oh my
goodness there's not not much gt love
out there right now is he coward right
now
that should be
no i'm not dead
that's a nasty frame trap and ikawan
with this
this dragon ball super team this is
this is interesting man i'm we're seeing
some when i said when we started the
bracket bro and and i mentioned that
we've seen some good character variety
today
we're getting some of the most character
variety i've seen in any kind of dragon
ball fighter's top eight in a long time
like yeah we're getting like you know
the repeated customers and we're getting
some of the uis the kid boos but bro
we're getting some some other like next
characters out here i'm enjoying this
yeah like legit this was worth waking up
at three o'clock in the morning like
legit like
no joke
yeah yeah i thought it was just going to
be kid boo's you guys and like you said
you were seeing those in like gogeta's
yeah not the blue one though i don't
think we can see the blue one yeah yeah
yeah yeah i know
things twice
i'm awake i'm awake i'm ready for this
this is uh
uh really sick to see coming from asia
because we're so i feel maybe in season
one in season two we was very used to
seeing okay kind of what what kazanoko
picks is what's topped here but these
guys are making all sorts of stuff work
uh hopefully we get to see a bit more of
the ginyu this time because we know
especially from eu
this character can snowball so strong
but what an escape that was so smart
yeah that was really really good right
there usually a situation where ginyu
just has full control but now i'm
finding a way out of it let's go get the
hit now
going to work here
yeah tyrone i think he's brown bread
that was a 2 star yeah yeah
you might be right you know
yeah that that that could be right there
these level ones do a lot of damage
boom hit right here and then
assist we do not see that that often
yeah i mean
he's just so godlike right
[Music]
yeah outside of twitter combos i i don't
really see hit c
uh
chad's ib told me to just not look at
any combos with her seeing it but it
made top eight so i'm gonna have to have
words of it maybe something you might
want to look into right now
cayenne making it work
like the delay right there on front
house pressure oh my goodness okay a
second c4 if he's gonna spark
dash beats to 5l kevlar swinging
draining all of this spark time
yeah man look at that it's great wait
drop combo oh my goodness and the drop
combo again what's happening
up here that one through
[Music]
oh my gosh this is
the hit specialist just absolutely
erasing chibu off the face of the earth
what
in the corner i didn't even see how
close he was regardless that is gonna be
it
just when you thought you had a you had
one up on on nikon right this guy just
brought out the hit nonsense
just
excellent play and he's gonna take it
2-0 probably it doesn't matter if you
happy birthday this man the hit was
there he was waiting in the back
to show up when the time was right and
boy did he ever
awesome stuff
completely time-skipped him completely
time-skipped if i don't know how he made
that comeback with hit a character that
we
very very rarely see uh do well in an
anchor position but with that spark
everything seems to be so
so potent when it comes to mix-ups and
the damage is outrageous just
literally one punching people to death
with the uh with the cannon super it it
went down to to to hear the end and he
was just like you know what like i want
to flick the switch i'm winning this now
um but we can see some action on the
screen right now guys from throughout
the set
it was an exciting one for sure
manny cohen just coming through with
this unique dragon ball super lineup
team
um kefla gogeta blue hit and it really
did work and i feel like kepler
is one of the characters that was
heavily improved not only in
you know character buffs and character
changes and things like that but the
system mechanics really really did help
this character a lot and i feel like
she's moving more into that position now
in the t list where she can be like
almost the glue that holds your team
together you know what i'm saying
she's a really really strong character i
feel like and
i'm glad to see more people picking her
up because i'm a i'm a big careful fan
in case you can tell
she's cool
i i think she's very interesting i think
and something we saw uh in that match up
with the with the dash and it's called
an assist behind it i think the dash is
like really really strong and not just
because of what it does she's the only
character that has that uh and
especially from doing it from like jump
to the like in the air to the ground um
by the time you realize what side she's
on you're not really expecting an assist
and if it's an invincible assist like oh
jeez um
and the confirms are so easy right from
assist now right there's a lot more hits
done on them so people get really uh
concentrated and clean confirms of it
right there's no like super dashing
because they don't know if they're gonna
make it time there's so much hits done
you get really sick confirmed and
a neutral tool like that is very very
important so yeah i agree with you i
think kefla's very very uh
diverse when it comes to how she can
play dragon ball
absolutely man absolutely well said um
so here we go guys we are gonna move
into the next match uh the final match
of round one of our tournament here
today it's gonna be verdane versus moja
so um
let's get it
all right
oh my goodness and of course oh here we
go
rocking
the vegito blue
this character he's been using lately uh
the the hit at the cell sorry and of
course that signature zebra that you'd
expect to see from brother oh my
goodness 2s where you going mojo's out
here
yeah mojo with some big buddies of his
own right jiren and c broly but yeah
like you said it's so cool to see the
danes sticking with the season one stuff
right so
zebra he was region-locked
in the previous season like we said
right about being big buddies he
he was definitely
a character locked from playing and
participating in a lot of matches but
right now
bro
you can see verdane second-guessing
himself there getting the execution
error with the 6m
um about mojo bro i tell you what jiren
as well this character oh my goodness
seconds water combo delaying it brings
in the big body good stuff right there
yeah nice i start from the dane right
but here we go mirror matches
oh
never mind no mirror matches right now
the geo mates is an entrance turned off
he's big damage oh the whole squad's
getting involved with his convertible
yeah
sell it sell as well as another
character back just man he was improved
so much this patch um and cell's an
interesting one i feel like cell's been
up and down the tier list a lot more
than most other characters in the game
he was like super good then he was kind
of whatever then he was like you know he
was strong again he keeps going up and
down
yeah i've noticed that i don't even know
if it's because of his toolkit right i
think most of it oh that was dark that
was pretty messy but i think it's more
just because of the metal right because
i think he's always been strong but
sometimes he's not strong at what's
winning games i agree with you yeah like
he definitely moves up and down due to
the game changes but here we go for dane
right now is cooking mojo could be in
trouble here piccolo's going to take
some damage for sure
yeah dragon rush six bars
[Applause]
hey man when this character's on the
screen that is not the one you want to
be fighting against oh my goodness from
the chest pump
yo the spark plate paid off right there
for the game and mojo they're gonna
waste all this spark time
yeah putting in and hard knock that
situation once again piccolo water
escape demon elbow
he's just throw out there oh my goodness
just super dash things guys
brother when that happens is a
heartbreaker because you like did i
really do the wrong thing okay wait he's
out
yeah he's got chances big five hate no
way tyrant no no no i'm going back to
sleep i'm not dealing with that
that
now my man
was okay okay i'd like to say that was
like the sickest read ever but did he
actually just do larry and then that
came out instead like yeah it's not me
i'm i'm not gonna lie and i'll be i'm
gonna be really honest with you and the
chat if that was any other z brody i
would have said it was it was a fluke
they were trying to go to train or
something but because it was the day
yeah i think you did it on purpose bad i
think you did it on purpose
we'll give him that one we'll give him
that one you know the zebra og
uh really sick stuff man man just said
nope where are you going why are you
trying that it's not happening
where are you going oh that was too sick
you had to just turn around like i went
i know you're gonna be there and i'm
gonna meet your your elbow with a nice
big crap snatched piccolo up by the
antennas bro just like you know shaking
for his for his lunch money yeah i mean
like what you're saying give me
your coins
i'm the
you got true
in your blood i'm just a demon hold this
see bully man this character is just so
and you know what like it's interesting
to me to see like character guys like
verdane doing work because
uh
japan
were not believers of z bully for a long
time they didn't see it you know they
they tried dabbling with him we saw it a
little bit in the national championship
but they weren't really there with the
character but you see guys like but then
you're just like man
just always been there bro
yeah 100
maybe not doing the work
you know in the big high stakes offline
environment maybe not traveling around
the globe and showcasing the skills but
you know that could also factor into it
i feel like this character going to work
is super super scary right now mojo is
showing us the strength of z let's go
yeah and i think a big part of what he
was talking about as well might be i'm
not sure what about how regions think uh
where they think they should be played
right angle position or point and i
think a lot more people will start to
play more point and utilize his kind of
ignorant neutral tools basketball with
assists
yeah yeah yeah i know i i i
you can definitely definitely be played
like that he's one of those very
versatile characters actually that he's
super scary wherever you put him so yes
all right let's go man
right here look at this what a
turnaround c4 this is mad yeah he wasn't
happy about how he got grabbed at the
last game neville davey neither would i
be so you gotta let him know show him
your zebra as well but the dane
point them in the corner
and this is gonna be knocked down here
of course forcing that blue combo just
chilling
hey
that's
is kind of ridiculous i can't even like
yeah it's a it's a show that's
definitely been picking up popularity uh
in anything in n a for for a minute like
to see
the uh take from asia right now oh that
was the uh
heavy command grab as well so you're
gonna get extensions
mojo
that line up
man like this this team just
such a hard hitting squad they're going
to get the hit and then boom brings him
to jiren
oh my goodness staying though trying to
make this comeback happen hold the
counter
don't try that oh you try that one yeah
you're gonna get spun literally the
dolphin man himself is here
oh the dragon
oh man
jiren and he's up here gonna have to
optimize the hell out of this combo oh
yeah that was a hard hit the hard drill
for sure button
with the m stomp into the level three
okay let's go
i mean this is going to be a very hard
comeback what
is the bully
i think that's dead yeah that's going to
be a dead gerund for sure he will have
to spend all of his meetings to do so
but it's going to be worth it because
the alien is going to be out the picture
guys there we go
yeah i mean
not having resources though that's going
to be really hard i mean he's still got
the whole s game right uh z broly one of
these kind of standout
features is his 5s and grab i guess
synderjee
oh
mad dead character right there moja is
doing work guys what a turnaround from
that first game that seemed to be kind
of all the game you know like
wow you got you can't thought that
really we just saw the team composition
and we saw the power that
a broly on point can bring to the table
like you don't usually think about that
because you think about zebrally you
think about anchor position only you
know just having him to rely on if
things go go bad if things go sour but
you know there's there's lots of
different ways you can play the game
especially with the backup assists you
know the the piccolo to helping the
neutral
or the um
uh or you know or the journalists to
extend your combos whatever but um yeah
we see some of the action on the screen
right now and it was a really good start
for for dane
of course we are 1-1 here in the match
right now so we will have another one on
the way but this is just some of the
little highlights that we've seen so far
guys
yeah super explosive back and forth uh
seeing you know the players at their
best on either side right
and again like you said just to harken
back into what tyrant was speaking about
before
the strength of z broly being able to be
played on anchor or on point he utilizes
assist and spark super well that was
savage that's
that's gonna be a highlight for the
whole championship that's i don't know
if i'm going to be seeing anything
better than that that was such a call
out
such a cool
you love to see that kind of stuff man
especially in these uh these big high
stakes tournament scenarios but we do
have the final game here on the way off
the set guys um for dane versus moja who
is going to advance on into the losers
quarters to play against nekoze um let's
find out and let's find out here
yeah who's this is out the tournament
brav
yeah that's that's the heartbreak
alright
oh that's why that's why it took a
little bit longer we haven't had okay
character change tyrant
playing double z movie bosses look at
that team right there cooler and broly
man with the cell in the back that is a
team of villains if i've ever seen one
this is a blockbuster team man yeah man
oh my goodness
lord
the great here we go
knock
out there and he's gonna this is a great
chance because he gets to switch out
into a different level three yep into
the cell solar kamehameha the perfect
stance coming home look at that yeah
yeah yeah
oh fated tyrant he knew from yesterday
he had that in his diary he was on the
calendar he knew he was going to burst
that was so sick that was so sick
okay here we go
oh he got cancelled in but for dane
already committed to the 214
okay how did he know to counter there he
was so ready that was sick yeah he was
ready for sure
man like jiren though here we go not
down time but they know i mean the spike
is still available don't think he's
gonna use it here but let's see
oh okay not bad he does he was scared of
the demon mix up you got hit by before
okay we've got water wall chris brown
combos let's go put him on the ground
right now into
all right gonna get some good oaky on
this situation c4 let's see what he goes
for man like the dane the zebra king
oh it's a cross up so scary to deal with
piccolo goes down no more big green guys
for this set
that's so sick right because we've seen
zebras try to tend to keep you in the
corner for like the grab kind of mix but
yeah the dane the og opting for the the
left right very potent
all with punish
do not with that 2h man
okay here we go final character in it's
going to be jiren
man this character is so scary universe
11's own but
here we go let's see if we can make
something happen he's going to
pull out a miracle to be honest but it
can be done it's not gonna be easy i
mean he is the strongest right and with
reflex like that could make the job even
easier to do
moja has definitely got a chance to
bring his back he's got a bag of mia
look at that he's still got kitkat and a
bit left
five and a half bars yeah man
he's out here let's go
that's gonna be z villains out here oh
they both try bruv the brains are too
galaxy i can't i can't
they they both thinking five steps ahead
but mojo making things happen here jiren
is out here bro area 51 let's go
oh my god
i don't think it could go from this but
it's going to be literally one touchy
yeah okay here we go
look at this what a comeback it was
looking impossible a minute ago but bro
the big body alien
wait a second not like this
the damage is going to be huge but you
can't kill c4 you need one more
do you save the bar yeah you save it
tournament
dragon
rush
oh he went for the dragon rush man it's
so so so many options to think about
there like is he going to count out
yeah of course that counter does not
lose um
does not beat dr's anymore well one of
his counters doesn't
uh
so you know the one that did before
where he got nerfed he's another another
thing that got nerfed about the you know
the characters in the game only a couple
characters received those direct nurse
jiren unfortunately was one of them with
the uh with the s counter um
and yeah he's gonna go down and man like
for dane going to advance on the zebraly
hero
so he's going to be going up against
nekoze
in the losers quarters
but we've got um a different match
coming up in a moment but here are some
of the highlights
from the action we just witnessed guys
and it was a bit of a bit of a brawl to
be honest
oh yeah like to say the least uh 2z boat
i mean all the big bodies are out today
all of the big bodies uh cooler
zebraly's
uh cells i mean piccolo's pretty big he
just doesn't look he's got he hasn't got
a good posture but he's in a big buddy
we're seeing some
crazy character character choices out
here man like really ones you would not
expect from japan of all regions you
know a region where
so many years we've seen like
you know just play the meta the gt
goku's the uis kid boo
you know etc like all like the standard
characters today we're seeing the
complete opposite bravo this is
topsy-turvy land i'm seeing like all the
all the choices the whole character
uh the whole roster
all the varieties in there and uh this
is the bracket how things have unfolded
so far fellas
yeah there we go verdana nicosia in
quarter finals like you said in the
loser's side
uh yeah none of these matches i think i
can call right i mean
if we go back and look at winners finals
because
versus pepe
their matches were super like
like you said the game that i talked to
toby bizarro world like one minute it
was looking really bad but when their
team
did what they were like meant to do on
paper what they were constructed for
they look super strong and
go tanks mirrors yeah
i'm talking this is what i'm talking
about man we got gotenk's mirrors in you
know in in in the current patch of the
game
in an online masters event so
bro
i'm not uh uh it's kind of crazy like
you love to see it more people exploring
what the game has to offer trying out
different teams not just you know
falling into oh i see this person
playing this so i'm going to play this
as well they're exploring different
options um and you know whether it be
the steamroll team we're seeing from
kuzuma's or um you know this
the the
explosive
uh gameplay that we're seeing from some
of the other players here it's really
really cool and i'm i'm thoroughly
enjoying this bracket man i wasn't sure
what to expect because normally when uh
when i've been up at this time
commentating the japan events
uh like for the national championship
for example it's like
okay it's gt goku it's ui
you know it's standard stuff
you know all like the standard stuff but
right now i'm seeing a wealth of
characters yeah it's awesome this is
this is dope
super super sick man like you said uh
seeing the
the what works characters that's what
we're very used to seeing right but now
we've seen
the teams and characters are like in
theory i think i can do this and i'm
gonna you know present it here
on the uh tenkaji master series and the
new phase been a real good showing i
like you've been saying tyron
hit c
it's
[Music]
oh my goodness that was an awesome chase
right there from this kepler look at
that
oh i went for the 2l but i got him into
trouble attacked by the assistant now
look at this cowan going back to work
here with kefla and it's similar to that
ghost strategy that we saw from uh from
the go takes place earlier he's just
getting that knocked down wherever he
can oh my goodness wow
airborne yep
just like the animation showed you our
dragon rush when he's doing that things
absorb all the id after that was cheap
so cheap he got
declined to
spark
wow
and using the held vanish there to
extend the combo and the css from hit
paying off look at this extension right
now and he is going to get enough bar to
get the kill look at this guy go to work
brush i'm loving this
that is
that's insane damage you know that
started with an assist
i'd have to tell some guys from the uk
about history man they didn't believe
turn them into believers yeah
oh he definitely didn't want that this
is gonna be massive punish right here
he's just gonna wait get a medium oh
maybe not
bro
there's no landing recovery on it either
so it's like it's really awkward
you could have gone for a 2h but you
want to go for max damage in it okay
yeah there we go all right he's making
up for it now he does get the hit on ui
draining the spark as well
oh look at this i guess they're hitting
cow and going to work
youngest of combos yeah actually no no
here
let's probably exist maybe not the
longest combo yeah
[Music]
for real man those are the real
feature-length combos man they're
draggable fighters much less go another
hitting is just looking unstoppable
yeah this is uh
such a
odd team to see on face value but the
way that it's been showcased here is uh
it makes sense it fully makes sense i
don't know if i could explain it to
anyone but the way
he can play in it it looks real sick
oh my gosh oh my goodness forbidden
starters as well second hit of auto
combo and he's gonna get enough damage
here to get the kill for sure bro
there we go
and that's it
bro that was a quick game
but to be honest that was one side of
his help
yeah
yeah
it was just it was just non-stop just
pressure and offense from mccowan like
potential just could not get going it
was literally just a
absolute onslaught of
just pressure and you know non-stop
you have to defend non-stop and it's not
always easy man dragon ball fighters if
your defense is not top notch you're
going to get killed real quick so
it looked rough
yeah i think uh i mean not even just
like this region i think a lot of people
when they construct the team or they uh
you know have a game plan they they want
to run their script with as least as
less fuss as possible right you just
want to go can you deal with my my plan
a with my
my you know my standards yeah before i
have to bring out all the the gimmicks
and trickery and the player versus
player stuff can you just do it with my
team and it's
i don't know man that carefully hit
stuff was pretty potent yeah and
he's using
he's he's using kefla in in the same way
like you know
it's he's just spending the world
immediately jump forward get the hit man
he's going just on fire right now
knocked down here goes for the safe jump
keeps it as simple as possible
and look at that you just have to defend
the whole time oh my goodness tap dr
catches the reflect and look at this
again
this is going to be straight back into
that the ray zone i think it is yes
non-stop
block
let's roll if you can force your
opponent to use spark in the first 20
seconds c4 that is a big win for you 100
100 and here we go trying to use the oh
i mean
one for one trying to keep the momentum
but 6m tyrant i
think he's dead
he got he got the hit there uh with with
the the overhead and then the follow-up
but then the 5m and kefla actually reset
the combo so it was a super fast kill
oh good reactions
s right there gonna get that counter off
and now look brings it to the corner
stance let's go
[Applause]
yeah looking pretty one-sided again like
you said but at least sparks off the
table for both players so
oh
man opened up again blocking hit can be
a nightmare sometimes but let's go
that's gonna be another dead character
on the board and the cowan is again
trying to speed round his opponent here
once that spot in the losers semi-finals
in top four
definitely games done quick moment right
now trying to get us over as quick as
possible windy punches get blocked by
the point blank super dash again
they're classic
yeah and we're really seeing that so
often that's becoming such a common
theme in dragon ball fighters recently
man that oh my goodness reset
come on crap that was nasty
but yeah i was just
gonna mention how many people are using
kind of goopy assistant neutral right
now along with the movement options to
get the hit and then convert but right
now
is just looking for that single hit to
close this out
okay potential though here we go this
might be the first bit of offense he's
had the whole set of
yeah i think this is like the yeah i
think you're 100 right this is the most
consistent that he's looked so far he
gets a ui level three i'm gonna have the
cooler position but
it's uh so he's as good as the corner
right with the mix he's got and there we
go again
in front with the super dash and he's
gonna get level one here to get that
kill
yep that does the job but you've got
this universe six duo coming in here
we've got hit and kefla let's see what
happens
yeah this hit has been looking like a
menace today in this top eight
oh opened up again bro it's been the
super dash every time
yeah i mean ui sneezing on a guy
that's good to hear
get in the corner
you need to go away that water converts
iron he nearly got away with it
very very nice
good stuff right there for cowan who
advances on guys got he's going to be
moving into the losers semi-finals um
potential bows out the tournament here
still gets himself you know
some some points on the board if you're
competing in the tenkaichi online
challenge you know you want those points
at the end of the day uh you will get
some for placing fifth but bro it's all
about those big juicy triple digit
points that's what you get from you know
moving up and up and up into the uh the
the top fours the top threes
um but that was a great performance
right there and we could see right there
unfortunately the level three went the
wrong side and he waited and didn't even
get the punishment
yeah i mean we'll never know right he's
the best who's the strongest one you
know who the better one it's definitely
for geo but yeah he's the strongest one
we'll never know because they refuse to
fight each other apparently yeah i mean
he didn't even want to punish him he
couldn't bring himself to do so um
but yeah that was a great great showing
for he can when it was just a non-stop
onslaught of pressure and right there
there was the combo reset that was a
heartbreaker for for uh
potential
but man like man
this this guy account is looking so good
dude this hit
beast i need to wait who actually beat
him to put him in losers i need to see
this i'm gonna look at this right now
ralph what what a showcase though uh
yeah
yeah super strong like you said the hit
has been
terrorizing all the opponents so far
that i've seen in this uh top eight
um
i think he lost like first game it looks
like and look at the bracket here yeah
it looks like ecowin lost like first
game yay
yeah he lost first game to a dude called
um
uh
cassato
kakato
so bro for him to lose first game to
someone that didn't even make top eight
and then we're seeing how strong he is
he just doing it like you know what i'm
saying like that's the level of uh
of play out here in japan and you never
know bro like these these
guys that perhaps you might not have
heard of doing work of course you count
one of the ones we do know out of the
bracket but there's a lot of these guys
perhaps we haven't seen before and
they're just really really impressive
today so
um yeah really good stuff
that's oh okay zeus is out here with the
knowledge uh casato is a freezer cooler
dragon ball super broly player okay so
even outside of the top eight there's
some unique character choices you know
what i'm saying like that's sick really
cool
i would love to see uh s broly he's yeah
same he's definitely one of my favorite
characters but uh
alas we can get two z broly's instead
which is this is close enough i mean
he's got three films he's got he's got
some love right i'm gonna see another
one right now as it's verdane going up
against because he
had not complained man the throwback
[Music]
[Music]
scary scary scary lineup
yeah
like you mentioned earlier
playing perhaps a um
you know
a couple of these characters we're used
to seeing that in japan you know
especially you know those are the
characters that we have seen
more times than most in dragon ball z
like that kojita blue definitely uh
definitely spicing things up
100 100
you know what i'm not i'm not even mad
because those two characters kid who and
bardock are so reliable they're old
reliable right they're the yes they're
the things you don't throw away because
you know you can always they're always
going to work they're never going to let
you down what they do is so consistent
and look right nothing flashy
just straight to the point either the
man with the bloody bandana fighting for
his people takes out
takes out one of the strong strong
opponents and uh strong characters on
the dane side but see broly's still
amongst them and now he's gonna do
himself
absolutely man oh he actually got a
medium off this table big man oh no you
missed it unlucky i do like that combo
that battlefield started to do
definitely yeah i feel like the you know
the characters that we talk about being
kind of dry whatever you know we've seen
them for many many years
from those characters these days you
know the options are available
yeah you know it's just down to the
players to to give us the
the nice viewing experience so to speak
you know
yeah yeah you got up the levels of uh
being bees eventually right yeah
the advanced stuff because being beads
then they find new advanced stuff but
they're not going to see anything more
advanced from bardock as he gets put
into a mountain by the daisy broly
yeah for sure but uh he said do i look
like that's brony i'm not the one in the
film oh okay goody said it doesn't
matter which brother you are you're
going to lose the same way
you're not holding this exactly it
doesn't matter bro you know this man
transcends uh he transcends
the cannon or not you know yeah
yep he said i saw the scripts i win this
i don't care what
what brother you're from
three movies one movie doesn't matter
you're catching hands catching hands my
overall you can catch these hands bro
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is definitely there
immediately though oh no
he's gonna die with the worst movement
in the entire world oh my goodness
that hurts
yeah
i think it was uh kind of
you could see in the approach that he
was trying to bait the spark right
uh and the point blank super dash takes
another victim with it it's like it
works so well
that has been the tale of today those
those jump same side super dashes have
been working
just an obscene amount of times man it's
been working a lot uh for these guys out
here um of course you know it's the same
kind of mind game as uh vegito blue same
side sword you know what i'm saying like
it's it's like okay i see them dash up
and jump and it's like i i
i mean the super dad has a lot more star
but your brain immediately tells you to
block the other way when you see someone
running and jumping that angle so
you know the japanese players really
getting a lot of mileage out of that but
man right now is down to
um verdane to turn things around here so
let's see how it goes
yeah let's even get it started i feel uh
the last match
i i think he kind of got bamboozled
right there was a lot of pressure put
into me to start
uh
the bardock man like
the barbic is so
straightforward and you know it's a good
testament to that character oh we've got
boolean this time it's a good testament
to bardock because it's like we've seen
this character for years but he's so
consistent it doesn't matter that you
know his options he's still going to hit
you
yeah the danny going for the the cooler
now opting for uh opting for their big
boy
okay oh my goodness she got two
oh bro that's a shame the three h worked
that [ __ ] bro no follow-up
yeah happy birthday there
[Music]
okay i'm trying to make up for it right
now
oh damn he got locked down
oh no bro
the spiral arrow the 2mm
that's a that's going to be huge
yeah in it
spark up though
these feathers are swinging he jumped
out of the command
he was ready but it's not enough at the
end of the day still gets to hit and now
through level three
yeah yeah he just came in for the uh the
album cover he didn't
he he didn't appear in any any tracks
just
he's just there just posing bro he
didn't do anything
just chilling
okay jump nice
here we go so
you're going to spend the three bars i
think he may there we go
if he can force neko to spend the spark
now that's a big win for him
wow
i mean a lot of people expect now
left right mix in that situation right
yeah
but bro he just stayed in front and that
went low got that kill on kid and that's
a massive w
yeah that was super slick that frame
kill got me flinching that like he was
on like a ddr map like he just done
something and then just straight to him
when people expect the rolling crush now
he just got on the same side okay here
we go
staggering reflects nice and delayed so
didn't get frame traps
caught by a straight h and i'm ready
with the reach up there oh my goodness
stop it
yeah that's it
another level three okay now neko's he's
gonna really have to think about
spending spark here because you do not
want to get hit by myself
he got hit with the left right oh my
goodness he didn't spark and he's gonna
pay for it losing bardock and now it's
all up to the blue fusion
tyrant i think he was wrong cooler did
more than before he gave cell bar he was
the beast he was the battery
no exactly yeah he served his purpose
man
the veteran with the
old school cell and
the broly
we've seen it like three or four times
man yeah same these fellas ain't ready
and that's a level three spark available
for nicholas a that's a gel free card
right there
oh yeah you're very right he's not gonna
have to oh
my god you can't do that bro
don't even try it level three going up
here
again it doesn't matter what what broly
it is i don't matter cannon or not
okay i'm punching you up it's going to
end the same
okay
it's that time but then it was uh you
know a little bit closer
for sure
damn i probably you've got the the
re-drive into a 2h from there just a raw
supermarket this is
bad yeah we need to talk about that for
a second that was kind of sick
bracket man that was a great performance
from him um that will be the end of that
hero you know definitely one of the fan
favorites out of japan
but he's going to bow out with the fifth
place finish and it is nekoze who's
going to advance on to play against
ikaiwan in the loser semi-finals guys
the top four is now set
let's go
sick and i think this is where
the the points difference really matters
in top four because first and second
they're big boy points that's that's a
lot of uh points in the bank to get you
to the uh regionals so
time to get the deodorant out time to
get mad sweaty yeah gonna have to bring
out all the stuff
all the stuff absolutely and we've seen
some some really uh interesting
teams today like i did not expect to see
some of the teams that we've seen today
but it's just going to keep on getting
more interesting guys coming up next we
got a go tanks mirror in winners final
in
2021 like
incredible fighters at this point you
never expect to see that maybe at the
start the very start of the year when
gotenk was like ridiculous you know
before the new patch came out but bro
after the patch a lot of people dropped
this character weren't really feeling
him
it's gonna be crazy and we're just
seeing some of the action on screen
right now like the power of kojita blue
has been on display today guys we've got
to see the character so many times and
neko's a just really showing us that you
know with a couple of solid characters
backing him up he can be such a threat
yeah very very solid like we said oh
faithful like bardock kid boo they're
timeless characters they're honestly
really timeless and verdane and we can
see here with the z broly and the uh
cell he's been playing these these two
characters for years for years i know uh
broly was dlc i think he was like the
second or first maybe the second uh he
came out with bardock with bardock yeah
yeah so they've been out for a hot
minute and again we have to keep
repeating it he played this team when it
was character locked where it was not
meta viable to play this team because he
lost from one dragon rush right but he
stuck with it and he done a lot of work
in the offline scene as well and then
obviously offline kind of went away for
a bit he's clearly stuck with the team
and you can see the mastery right and
some of the combo routes the uh the
frame kills he did with celine got the
same side to him he just plays on
people's fears it's really sick to see
so it's unfortunate for him to go but
like i said nekoze played just super
fundamentally sound man there's nothing
we can take away from his play was just
on point yeah i'm really enjoying his
play man it's like you say fundamentally
sound at the end of the day really
really just effective
guys it's going to be gameplay versus
pepe and this is an interesting one um
purely for the fact that both teams have
go tanks like
i i i did not
jump on the stream today to commentate
and expect to see two go tanks players
in winning finals i'll say that much and
i'm sure you didn't i'm sure the chat
didn't we're all you know kind of uh in
awe today
yeah there's nowhere else could have
seen that i under 17. at 17 winners
finals in
asia and couldn't you could have told me
this and i would have said you're lying
a discord tyrant i would have said no
that's not happening no way
yeah it's here and wait we saw this you
saw this before right the steamroll
effect that this character has
yeah look at that he's gonna set up the
ghost okey got himself a ton of bar in
the process and now kuzumotsu going to
work and there it
is yeah and he okay so he used the ghost
is that the ghost for a single assist
there and he's got two more assists
available
but he's not about to kill he's going to
be back
for the same jump time okay there we go
yeah it doesn't opt for the luigi's
mansion mix oh he brings in the ranger
yeah 17 in there now oh my goodness
y'all what is going on bro stealing that
there's another look
let me write that one down go go
confused for a second the the the self
mix
okay
here we go pepe going to work right now
big elbow drops you down
jumps in with the asus behind that's
kind of nasty just to catch the uptake
just in case you know
yeah very smart oh and i'm telling you
point bank super dash is the strongest
mix
it's the strongest mix and this
universal brother everyone has that yep
fear and balance all couldn't count with
records for that guy council
unfortunately super dash right back to
get into the mix
very nice
okay grabbed up there good stuff
and now here we go oh no drop the combo
whoa
okay just stuff happening right now
yeah android's taken to the sky
that's confirmed
let's go because you must be right now
gonna get that knocked down here we go
again not enough to get the kill but
there's just been it's just been about
great knockdown situations and uh the
advantage side of things because yumatsu
whenever he hasn't had the bar to kill
it's always just been an advantageous
situation
yeah not 100
uh
again another drop man pepe going to
take advantage here but how much damage
is he going to get on this 21. knock
down maybe ghosts yeah
there we go we dimension time
oh we need to get the off of that ghost
unfortunate in the scrabble
pepe got caught
yep
hey i'm gonna go for the level three yep
all right here we go
let's see what the is going to be here
for kuzumasu because there's
obviously nobody don't think he can kill
even if he gets a clean hit right now
oh
that was risky but the covers in time
pushed right back to the corner
[Music]
out there on the reflect and a clean 2m
to get the punish and the kill
and now look at this is the true
gotenk's mirrors
yeah this is what we wanted to see
that
was grinding tyrant
ah he missed the self that he missed
solo recap there
i think he's gonna pay with that he's
gonna pay for that right because it's
time
halloween time yeah because it keeps it
super simple man like and it is it is
the case of simple but effective for him
um all the dunk go tanks is out man
17 left
let's
go this is a definitely a struggle it's
going to be hard but only like half
health as well it's got a bit of bar but
yeah you can't mess with tell your
normals man characters with tails
they play a different kind of neutral
and 21 with some of the the longest
reaching buttons in the game into some
of the most you know it's one of the
reasons so it's just it's just another
reason why she's considered like you
know one of the top characters in the
entire game man just amazing range
amazing damage the okay she gets
the options that she has she's just
overall just an absolute
just just a complete package of a
character and you know she can go on any
team
just
an absolute beast and bro kuzumasu off
to a great start here in the winner's
finals and let's see man pepe gonna have
to turn this around because he was
looking rough right there
yeah i think the the round start just
got
got taken away from him
he
both recap both the teams definitely
have that snowball effect right getting
the first hit they don't really have a
very strong comeback factor uh i think
they can lose once or twice in neutral
but when they start losing characters i
think it gets really peak for that team
so
it's gonna be hard and i feel uh maybe
with pepe's team his team relies a bit
more on bar where kaz just needs one bar
for ghosts and then he can just kind of
set play you to death
so that's kind of the drawback to his
team but hopefully we can see it go the
other way you know you are on point this
time
[Music]
already off to a fantastic start man
because
he is gonna just and he uses both the
assists in his combo because once he's
out the ghost
you are waiting and you know you're
getting that cool down back regardless
you know you're going to extend your
comment on the ghost and then you've got
two more assists to use it's just such a
good strategy
out of course you can get the knockdown
again boom back off set up the ghost
again and then the next hit that's a
good character like i love the strategy
yeah and that was like me a perfect did
he had exactly the right amount of bar
for that like
this is a lads this is lab scenarios
this isn't like parkour combos like he's
he's done this millions of times
[Applause]
wait a minute the supernatural off there
for pepe okay you are goku now
but there we go
just okay firing off
okay oh the 6m with the 17 assists
behind it
oh wait a second oh oh no yeah dropping
those here
is that a thing i didn't know punches
beat super dash rider 236 h bro with the
right yeah
with if it's active you'll blow it out
for sure
sick
income is 21. all couldn't stop that
super dash
all right 117 right now
i love the androids right now
robot wars
no punish though
yeah put that five in my way get scooped
up 21.
put 17 down
mathematics
barrier season of the barrier guys by
the way
yeah yeah
okay nice he stopped there gets the
smash effect knocked down and that's
gonna be a dead android 17 man
yeah and
it always feels bad when you get hit by
the uh the mid because that's all it was
he was cool probably holding up back
maybe trying to back dash press a button
and it just didn't come out the right
timing but yeah that is like the worst
way to go you're like damn if i just
stood still i'll be alive but
because mutsu not caring about that just
trying to get the win trying to move on
to grand finals oh my goodness yes he is
indeed kuzumu everything working out for
him right now man this gotenks on point
team um is looking so good i'm getting
flashbacks of uh kazunoko at the
national championship finals man like it
was all about that go tanks oh my
goodness what a confirm
here we go
assist on deck as well
he's got one more if he needs it
probably won't spend it because there's
no point yeah the damage is too high the
scaling
uh sorry the scaling was too high there
oh my goodness have you got the assist
there here it is
i think that's dead
[Music]
you think
[Music]
oh
what we saw there
was actually okay so here we go season
three that would have killed right but
the re jumps now that gotenks
has
with the machine gun punches into the
the the 214 l right and then he gets the
re-jumps the damage is scaling on it's
way higher now so like yeah he used one
of those in the combo room it just it
basically
it's like 500 less damage than you would
have got before or something like that
like it's right the scale yeah they
that's one of the direct nerfs that he
received actually his re-jumps now do
like way less so yeah yeah they uh i
mean i remember when i saw it i was like
damn they need to get a scooby-doo and a
gang on that because i don't i don't
know where the scaling was the scaling
was definitely not there the scale was a
mystery
yeah it was it was it was kind of crazy
but bro with that kuzumatsu with a 2-0
lead right now um
over pepe and he's looking really really
really strong um
honestly like the way he's playing this
go tanks team is built around just and
we and we saw it the meet a perfect game
to get these combos off is really really
effective
oh my goodness what a start though spark
yeah hello you just
stopped that with one assist call oh
tolhan is he gonna fall out no he
doesn't he's still there
okay
he wasn't sure okay he wasn't sure right
there i think that if he done the um
wow
the panic button was smashed right there
because he wants to he was like you know
what i'm doing it
when he did that all i heard was you
know in the manga stuff when you hit the
mean button
that was actual panic
yeah yeah that was that was the
man i had to call an emergency on that
one yeah i had to call a meeting all
right here we go though
still got a deadly duo going on though
with go tanks with 21.
yeah this can get done there we go the
skating in full effect as we see
the dark reset that was nasty bro
dead
okay
here we go
i mean yeah because i'm not so saying
that i don't need tohan he's there for
the damage but uh
like he said that
the concept the strategy the synergy of
his team is still intact even with two
characters yes it just means he gets a
little bit less damage and he has one
less assist to use in neutral right
man and it's working out there oh my
goodness pepe is just still locked down
regardless that's gonna be massive
damage and m punish in the corner with
go tanks bro this is gonna be crazy
shout cancel combos and 21 assists
available as well knock down back off
set up the ghosts let's go oh wait he
actually dropped it
yeah i think he did i'll try to him
okay
oh my goodness look at the
this come back here from quizzy muscle
he didn't care about the happy birthday
start but let's go pepe right now
brings in
android 17
oh oh yeah
that's so sick that's such a sick way to
uh synergize your team taking taking to
the beach yeah get the volleyball let's
go yeah yeah you're right man now that
you know now that you can use the 17
wreckers in the air and bring them down
bro the damage potential now from those
airborne combos and the z changes is
kind of crazy right
super sick yeah i think he brings so
much to the team now and pepe getting to
demonstrate it right because before the
other two matches because mutsu was kind
of running away with it but now
pepe getting to work are we gonna see
some uh ghosts on his side oh no
okay delay spark there just in case it
was a bait oh the super dash every time
oh my goodness android 21
is gonna just cook right now get this
god okey on the level three gonna get
all the stocks as well
okay
trade hoffman i receive
okay
how does the medicine taste how does the
medicine taste but
i don't know
how there
yeah
oh
my goodness every time bro online
super dashes are just they're the one
man
they are it's a nightmare to deal with
the tail normals
can't mess with him
can't mess with him
okay not bad though this is going to be
great okay but not dead
he said i think
that was so sick bro we tried it galaxy
okay it's gonna be yes for the game i
think after this
yeah
i think so okay here we go what's it
gonna be now we might have to hold this
record pressure oh it was the ex off the
jump
button there and pepe stays alive in the
winner's final set guys days are live
with one game up on the board here
against because in monsters two still
gonna have to win two more games if he
wants to advance onto the grand finals
but man that was a great way to keep
yourself in the game but man i feel like
the game started with that happy
birthday right gohan essentially getting
wasted real quick kuzumasu essentially
played that entire match with just two
characters because
and we saw how well he did like he hung
in there with two characters
um his strategy basically remained
intact
pepe was able to
pull that back and stay alive barely
barely barely but made it happen
yeah i think you he showed that he can
play without the dp assist right and
even though that brings you a lot when
it comes to like scrambles and being
safe when you approach
like you said because mozzarella showed
that he can play without it perfectly
fine obviously it wasn't enough but you
mean
that's that that is the risk you play
when you have an assist that you can you
feel like you could freely throw at
because you can get stuffed out right
and that's what happened to tolhan so uh
shasta pepe for uh clutching that one
out oh he's gonna have to do it two more
times he wants to make it through the
tournament in middleside still
indeed
[ __ ] great start here because you must
just back off there we go
that's up the ghost now
back to the faithful strategy and man i
feel like it hasn't failed like it's
just always been working out there and
guess the re-jump as well of course look
at the damage scaling now
to think that the damage on that was way
higher before it's
kind of frustrating to think about
actually i mean as a girl thinks player
i love it but like
it was it was a bit much man i can't lie
[Music]
it definitely uh to with some people i'm
not one of them because i just didn't
play go takes players i'm too smart for
that
[Music]
is just it's been 50 seconds of non-stop
action for him no stop
[Music]
he's running a script here we go luigi's
mansion again oh mr air to air
okay
oh my goodness oh we got two
of course he is this is a fantastic
situation for himself look at this
oh
you like out there man you are just
dying real quick and then boom to level
three coming up here father-son coming
home that's
just like that called the dp assist
and have you seen it have you seen the
free sticks of celery on kazumutu's side
has not
i had to jinx it my bad jackpot
you spent all the mp
man casted curse right there but it's
going to be man because of what she was
working on a perfect though like that's
that's the crazy thing about it
yeah super
the team the script that he's running is
just potent as anything yeah this
counter hit i don't know what they tried
to do but i had to try and go out
swinging right because blocking that's a
50 50 anyway you might as well hope that
they mess up and try man to come back
unfortunately
because
looks super super solid it's it's just a
a very uh practiced and rehearsed
set play he's got and approaching
neutral man i'm i'm loving it to be
honest with you like we're seeing some
excellent um you know unique teams out
here um encouragement definitely one of
those ones bringing the heat with that
super saiyan 3 team man the go tanks
team um
i'm loving it man like really really
good stuff and with that victory secures
himself a spot in the grand finals
um man that's a comfortable position to
be in a winner's side and right now it's
he's looking outside of work online the
way he's playing that team it just
steamrolls so quickly
it's super super scary um
but coming up next guys we're gonna move
down into the losers bracket but before
we get to that man we can just have a
look at some of this action right here
that was so good like and the fact that
bro he's using all of gotenk's tool sets
so well like it's he uses the shout
cancels uh like any time he can um using
the great neutral options calling the
assists very well
and it's he's just looking and looking
like a complete package of a guy right
there
yeah like i think he's literally making
like a gotenk's guide
on in a tournament match like you could
just get these vods and go oh this is
what you do with go things this is the
game plan this is the strategy this is
what he's good at uh and he's like you
said he's demonstrated a lot of stuff
like utilizing 2m in neutral and stuff
he's done a lot of uh reflect2m's and
back dash 2ms in like really clean spots
uh the ghost confirms have been really
interesting as well the the meat and
build roots
i think he's done pretty much everything
with it uh so yeah
he deserves to be in the finals for sure
oh yeah absolutely absolutely um
really really good stuff all right so
the gentlemen are just reading up guys
we are just getting the next match
for you coming up very very soon um but
yeah i mean we need to keep going back
to this point because it's the most
relevant point of the day some of the
character and team variety we're seeing
today is just
really really impressive man and like i
i didn't know what to expect and we can
see right here there's the spark up on
the on the happy birthday confirm and
look at that ui life bar just absolutely
getting rinsed
bro mad
yeah yeah i mean i'm obviously i'm a
little bit biased a tiny bit by us for
for pepe
i i'm all about uh the ranger man i
really like android 17
[Music]
so hopefully we get to see a little bit
more of him in losers finals but we're
going to see who he's up against first
from the semi-finals match uh nicosia
versus ikaian i'm not sure is this first
of three or first or two first two
first two right
yeah top three will be uh three out of
five right right but yeah we are moving
back down into two out of three
territory guys cohen versus nicosia so
we are going to see our uh the fan
favorite icon the hit warrior um the guy
that plays the entire dragon ball super
team
um
and you know another one of our gogeta
blue heroes out here you know it's gonna
be a blue showdown actually right now so
it should be great
more mirror matches of characters we did
not expect to see this early in the
morning i know i love it already i'm
still not ready i feel like i've i'm i'm
dreaming brother i'm having a bad dream
right now like
we're seeing high level japan action
with that gojira blue but um
there we go man nico's a rocking that
bardock
brav
this character never fell off man let's
be honest
never never
and i i think it's like
really cool that a character can be that
consistent through the through the meta
right and i think they didn't fall off
the mouth just other characters got
buffed i don't think he's ever like
falling off because what he does will
work to the end of time like his toolkit
is just very
uh fighting game-esque right it's very
fundamental
and he's still got like really quick
stuff larry is a very good poke he's
still got the lock down with the gut
punch and like he said back with kid boo
kim boo assist can make any character
work
yeah man that's so true man like it's
it's really really good
um all right guys here we are going
straight in now oh my goodness baited
out neko's a just continuing that reign
of terror that we saw against verdane
earlier on right here against mcgowan
okay the spark up realizing kefla was in
danger wants to keep her alive at all
[Music]
goes behind oh my goodness yo using the
214s teleport to get behind and just
cause a left right mix there very very
scary and there's another option that
kepler has in her arsenal
the head
he got bonked firm as well that was sick
yeah ready all guests reflect when you
survive somehow blocks the overheads all
of them but cannot take the dragon rush
and that is going to take bardock out
he's going to fall down at the rest of
the same brethren there you go
yeah very nice big bang come on how many
hard to close that one out and he cohen
just gonna bro here we go look at the
blue mirrors guys yes we're seeing it
this is not made up this is not a dream
this is not false
like it's happening
crazy stuff
nice
and like gogeta blue has some of the
best like
just you know mid-screen like super dash
confirms in the game i feel like you can
always get the slider knocked down you
can always get the uh bring it to the
corner quite easily
yeah this he definitely got less from
the last patch 100 100 percent
all right
level three time
for neko trying to get that hit guard
cancels in here oh yeah let's hope
okay look like you got one committed to
the um
option there
yo
go
hit beast oh wait you got the hit
it's
sticking to him like glue bro he said i
don't care if you reflect i'm on you
reflecting the hit can be so scary at
times yeah yeah yeah he damn he was like
gorilla tape right there bro he was like
i'm not going anywhere and i'm just
going to bully you in to get to and look
at this again super dash stopping any
sort of beam projectile coming out from
kimboo level three hands up in chat time
for you to guess echoes a kid boo your
life is on the line
pressuring away now oh my goodness the
double overhead kid boot in danger right
now don't think he can kill in this
situation neko zade does however have
seven bars to try and make a comeback
happen let's see if he can make that
miracles happen
yeah oh my goodness yo
that is the did you see how late the dps
is here any oh my goodness
like
bro the the the changes they made to
this to a lot of these assists and like
you know the hit stun now that you can
convert off is kind of nuts
um
just madness right there
yeah yeah it literally like and we spoke
about it a little bit earlier right the
the way that they've
patched the game to make
most teams viable right most teams are
viable now it's very more open than it
was before where it was kind of like oh
you kind of have to do this with your
shield to uh to be
competitive you've seen
two teams with uh with the dp assist
from gogeta which is really interesting
because his assist i think was something
that a lot of people looked at first
yeah
uh just having that basically a physical
beam that gave you a wall bounce alright
people were like oh that's that's super
strong that's really cool and we've seen
a c assist from kid boo which is very
popular and hit which is very unpopular
like i've hardly seen i think there's
two people on the planet that use that
and one of them's raptor and now you've
seen again do as well and yeah he's just
been playing out of his mind when hit
hits the field
it looks long for everyone on the other
side
yeah absolutely bro absolutely
very well said so here we go man moving
into the second game of the set now
let's see how this one unfolds fellas
yeah i want to see more of the uh the
mobility from uh kefla like the kefla
dash into a
dp assist was looking real grimy yeah
that's nasty man right it's just it's
just a simple left right mix you know um
you know you
at the end of the day
it is just
i mean it's not it's like the simplest
thing you can think of right but it's
just
it works so well
yep
wow
again tyron
the last minute confirms off of the dp
assist yeah man it's always so good
consistent man
consistency is key of course right now
though it is all about this kefla in the
corner sets it up and should be able to
get the kill right now yeah it keeps a
simple two bar spend
that's it
yeah
damn
oh my god
bro
are you kidding me
man it's so oh my
goodness i think that's like
a really creative way to use c assist
like
he icons using css to lock them down
even in the year because the tracker
seems to be good enough and then going
okay i'm just going to meet you up when
you land
yeah yeah exactly
right here look at this man because
they're going to work right now
down time level three on the way yes it
is
all right let's see how is he cowan
gonna defend from this i mean the spark
is an option as well
let's see
could be a very attractive option right
now yeah using it good stuff
reflect
there's no better way for you to waste
the opponent's spark climb then with a
medium start combo and look at this
right here
yeah bruce assist and he's gonna get the
kill as well on careful not only wasting
that spark time but wasting that
character let's go
that's perfect scenario right for
because in 100 perfect maybe not
thinking that they'll get the kill
through the spark i did and now
basically evening it up uh
just gotta navigate through that it's
the assist which didn't happen tara yes
that's it there we go going
getting the knock down now into the okay
into the hit level three
and let's see what the pressure
situation is going to be here nicosia
gonna have to try and defend
successfully but it's not gonna be easy
account has been okay just reflects away
good stuff there good good choice on
defense but the conversion again the c
assistant and he's going to get too bad
i don't think this is killed though
[Music]
oh
no
no
pixel but that's what kid who needs
oh there it is the 6m pays off
great scenario now okay
g a blue solo not the best character
unfortunately but let's see if you can
make something happen you never know
oh man you can't do anything about super
dash bro super dash has been
this this tournament has been all about
that super dash bro i swear like we've
seen so many situations like this yeah
yeah
we can't do that
it's not gonna happen bro that's gonna
do it right there boom
star dust fall into the hit super and
there we go cowan secures himself a spot
in top three of today's tournament wow
what a performance so far from recalling
man
yeah like uh going back to what you're
saying earlier about uh
losing the first game in this game
that's this is a hero's journey he's
made the complete run bro he lost the
first game of the day um
earlier on to to uh casatao casato and
then now boom ran all the way through
one two three he beat pakka earlier on
as well before top eight really yeah
really really strong player taking down
there um
yeah so he's just boom works his way all
the way through
and you know he's he wants to take it
all the way to the grand finals but he's
got one more opponent ahead of him and
it's gonna be a real tough one in um
pepe so
let's check it out guys
yeah this is a
it seems like we might be watching an
anime story in the timeline right
because first game like you said
and to make it this far and they're
looking so strong right just back to
back matches having to play twice as
much as uh kazumuzo in in winners
like it's rags the riches and
there's a rag on the left-hand side of
bardot the bloody rag
i i i think it i think it was my bad
guys i think i think it is three out of
five in all these semis
okay never mind
okay three out of five in the top four
guys i didn't realize it sorry my bad so
we are going to get more games all right
let's do it
that means this is a chance but neko's
aiding oh
my goodness
bro ready there
and i think this alertness is what uh
nakaze needs to uh
to bring back the 2-0 deficit to free to
if it's even possible right now
honestly there's no better way to sort
of you know make a statement back than
to just get that great start of the
round but man right now he counts not
making it easy he is firing back but a
fantastic defensive super dash evades
the command grab and he should be able
to get the kill here on kojita blue just
needs to close it out spend one bar
there we go
right yeah
here we go like you said okay the dream
is still alive
oh into the beam
that was unfortunate yeah oh my goodness
the hits done on that is nuts man
i can't believe it look at this necklace
firing back he has yet to be touched by
the way he has not taken any damage so
far in this last match
matt yeah yeah i mean
dominant performance this is definitely
it seems like a different character a
different player from the first two
matches
needs to make something happen we saw
him do some magic earlier with hit um
but it's gonna be a tough uphill battle
three characters and spark to deal with
bro that's essentially four characters
you've gotta take down here
yeah
try to step on these crepes
oh god block though insane block yeah no
conversion
here
hey man hello oh there it is dragon rush
and that's going to be a dead battle
catcher yeah yeah i mean even though bar
is going down because these blocks
at the moment are actually insane yeah
so we see we've seen some really good
defensive options actually from him um
let's see if we can keep up here because
this here is not looking like a joke at
all and this is the character that he
comes known for um you know this is the
his main chicken so to speak
the the seasoned it's got all the
colonel's spices on there
he's not been touched i know look at
this this hit man it's looking actually
ridiculous level three coming up
and now look at this like what a
turnaround because he could potentially
bait out neko's a spark
let's see how he deals with this let's
find
out okay there it is
oh my gosh this is actually time
skipping he can he's not been touched
hard i am shocked oh my god look at this
turn around
the second hit was on the screen okay
he's gonna spark up to guarantee the
kill here and this is a great option do
you know why
every time you're getting a combo whilst
you're in spark time that doesn't go
down whilst you're in limit break so
he's this hit coming in now
for the final round against kibbu that's
essentially full spark time again you
know what i mean whereas that boost
spark is going to be going down because
it's only level two yes
so
wow you come with a fantastic decision
and here we go let's see if we can make
something happen here
okay finally
finally
it comes hit
has been hit and it took this character
off all the characters in the game kid
yeah man okay
he's gone now free going but bro necos i
guess they're here and that should be
enough there after that after that scary
display of hit from econ neko they hold
it together with the kid boo and gets
the kill one up on the board to put
himself back in the picture here
just needs two more games up on the
board account needs one to advance onto
the losers finals
let's go
yeah that's uh
i mean if i was playing that hit ankara
would send chills down my spine man
because
you know what the thing is i would be
scared to snap him in to try and get rid
of him early because imagine how he
would play with assists on back in that
hit up
yeah that's a peak peak
yeah man it's it's it's like we said
that
character is um
that's that's the one that we all know
you're going for like there's there's
not many there's not many hit players in
general right but that's one of the ones
that a lot of people know about and you
know look up to and look at him for like
tech and you know the high level
gameplay so
yeah he's out here with that character
for sure man like he's scary with it
yeah that were i i've i've never seen
like a one character come back that
almost didn't get hit like it was almost
a perfect it came down to it yeah he
killed two characters without getting
hit
like that's impressive that's a a very
strong statement when it comes to look
at my neutral i've got no beam i'm just
doing martial arts i'm justified i'm
swinging punches speaking of swinging
punches kefla does get the hit yeah the
2m and then the delay five m sequence
there
to get the full combo
that was so sick to chase the larry out
of the corner
oh
man the css paying off right there is
definitely one of the better ones that
beam of course and now look at this
situation knocked down into the level
three
okay let's have a look here what's the
pressure situation going to be here for
can't do nekozei
oh no sidewalk was going for the longest
combo
dropped it
ready
you thought it was your turn didn't you
you really did you really thought it was
your turn but guess what
hell no
yeah unfortunate
okay what's i mean hard knock down
pretty good
yeah this is a great situation yeah dash
of pressure
oh my goodness bro two h on block into
two one four h gets a full combo off of
that and now look boom that's gonna be i
think that's a dead character actually
yep c assist on deck vr
level one
nice good sequence from recovering and
the first character goes down for
deposit
not a good look here in this fourth
fourth game
yeah and that kid who's done a lot
that's just unblockable tyron i don't
know what to tell you but he's kind of
cheap
silly cheap there's already enough to
think about when you're defending
defending against kefla you know you
could you've got to defend against 6h dr
the larry at low and then you've got a
throat you've thrown that left right
with an assist as well but that's even
yeah it's even cheaper
yeah yeah that's it's so cheap is buy
one get one free brother like it's just
what do you do against it
all backs off
didn't work out but
okay did send kefla away got fighters
about the corner but no doesn't do
i'm convinced now that that's not just
not that's just untickable it's
uncheckable to hit the ground
yeah that it actually looks like that
it's nuts
vegeta assist is the same it just like
juggles forever it feels like it's nuts
yeah okay and this is what i was talking
about this must be so scary here
it is hit with assists yeah it's looking
super long for men's that's three bars
it's gg's that's gonna do it for sure
bring them down to the ground switch out
to the big bang kamehameha and cowan
does with that victory advance into the
losers finals to play against pepe man
he's to go through the go tanks
the go thinks army right now it's not
gonna be easy but man what a performance
from me cowan um just looking so so
strong moving to top three and this is
where the points get real juicy
yeah yeah we were saying this before
right so 200 for first place 150
for second and i believe it's a hundred
for third so
with the ten catchy uh the community
ones
the most you can win i think is a
hundred if you come first
so it's really important here i mean i'm
this one is for
ichaion and he's in his journey from
losers spray up because he needs to get
sweaty now because this is what he's
been fighting for right from from round
one losing this is literally what he's
been fighting for yeah yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely so yeah guys we
are top three position now here uh at
the world championship
tenkaichi online master challenge japan
edition um yeah man i've been thoroughly
enjoying the bracket today i'm having a
lot of fun out here um man some of these
characters and matches have been super
super hyped so yeah we've got some more
interesting stuff on the way man we've
got three character specialists in top
three we've got like a really wide array
of characters
that are going to be on display here for
the losers finals and in the grand
finals so guys you do not want to miss
this it's been really really fun man i'm
having a blast
yeah i i
i love tournaments when you can't call
it right and yeah obviously in eu we see
a lot of tournaments and uh
with french players and germany and
switzerland and all that sort of stuff
so we can normally see what's going to
happen we've got an idea we're so
accustomed to the teams the players
seeing this seeing seventeen see and hit
hit c assist two doji is
uh two goat x's i know right
it's it's that it's definitely a breath
of fresh air for sure you know it's it's
really really tight to see
um and we are just getting the players
in the lobby for you guys to to enjoy
right now but thank you all so much for
for joining us today you know wherever
you're watching from um wait where's
everybody from right now because i'm
willing to bet we're not going to be
seeing many europeans many of our
european friends in the chat here
because boy it is currently 5 45
a.m in the uk right now um
kind of dj hours
yeah yeah sun's coming up man
sunday's coming up switzerland puerto
rico
let's go good to see everybody in there
espana i see you
us
yeah man good mix that's right
i think i think for the us it's kind of
like just normal hours for most of them
anyway i mean east coast is still pretty
late but like west coast is kind of just
like you know normal tournament viewing
hours i feel like
okay okay oh i see some uh uk and london
okay hey let's go
they're the real troopers out here man
good stuff guys
and you can see right on the on screen
guys you can see the bracket how we're
gonna have this top three unfold right
now it's currently losers finals pepe
versus ekawan
and man like
we've seen some crazy crazy crazy
characters today some really interesting
teams and we're gonna keep that moving
right here that theme has been an
ongoing occurrence but let's get it
i mean this guy we're pretty used to
seeing though we can be honest
yeah yeah he's he's kind of a staple uh
when it comes to
seeing
seeing the glory of like finals and
pretty much winning tournaments right
he's definitely a mainstay
kefla i think kevin was really popular
earlier on and kind of people just like
left her i'm not sure why maybe because
it was obviously stronger synergy right
as the dlc characters got released uh
but again like just having unique tools
can always keep someone on your toes and
i think ukulele's team literally has all
that all three of the characters have
something unique to them that the rest
of the cast doesn't yeah i feel i feel
like in this patch as well i feel like
she really did get improved a whole lot
um
yeah the france vs usa event i was
talking to some of the players about
this and man yeah she's looking scary
but let's get this off guys let's get us
off to a great start as well just as
peppa is with this full combo right now
ui goku going to work right now
nice extension of the seven assist as
well
yeah
down back off ghosts
oh no do you think he didn't get the
back dash he obviously wanted to do back
dash and then the ghost
[Music]
didn't come off that way
nope and now kefla
a lot of fusions here
yeah man potara versus dance okay got
the hit low and now
yep
combo in there for the smash effect and
now let's see can he extend enough here
i think oh he just dropped in c4 that's
unfortunate
yeah i was about to say that's such a
sick extension and now oh kefla had to
spark trying to i mean it was the fusion
dance but now trying to dance on
boatings but gori takes this swing in
the limbs
[Music]
yeah yeah three spots this this is the
combo you see on reddit this is one of
them convoys rather no way you're
surviving it
yeah that's it for sure
dead character
right there
pepe opened up again and cowan continues
his reign of terror
and it needs to be said again bro you
know
this guy lost his first match of the
tournament and now he's running all the
way through and here he is and loses
finals when does the stamina run out c4
bro it gets to a point where you start
to feel drained you know yeah
no like no doubt but i'm not even just
mentally i'll be physically fatigued for
having to play so many matches and in
every match going if i lose i'm out
that's it i'm done
yeah and it and it really becomes
evident once you get to this stage of
the tournament where matches are three
out of five and not just two out of
three but we saw right there pepe did
drop his android 17 combo that would
have been a dead goji a blue and look at
this kefla right now going to work gonna
get that extension that nice buff she
received this season the cannonball shot
into the dash
yeah reflect on wake up doesn't have to
block that damn that was such a good
snipe with the windy punch that was
clean ui
gonna get the knock down pepe fighting
if he's two characters remaining
okay
keeps the corner position vanished
oh my goodness
reflecting nothing but air and that's
gonna be a dead kefla potara fusion goes
down and now we're gonna move to the
dance let's go
for sure for sure yeah the uh guest
reflect is the number one killer in
dragon ball for sure a lot of people
fall down to that one
oh my goodness tap tap into the 2m for
the full combo pepe looking good but
look who's coming in
look who it is
the game started yeah the game just
started guys
this is the cowan's
definitely his strongest character
you've got to be so scared he's got full
health he's got seven bars 17 is deleted
yeah boom
shotgun get that guy out
scrap heap for him
totally
all right one more now
he just ran into his fists
oh my goodness
brown bread he's brown bread hit this he
didn't get touched again
martial arts just martial arts brother
that character
man you're really seeing why he's
regarded as one of the like stronger hit
specialists man like he just makes it
work like he he's making anchor hitler
broken like yeah usually you usually the
hit players they're not really you know
they don't feel great about it being
left with hit because you know they got
to rely on you know they either super
super super solid play or just like
non-stop gimmicks right
ecowin is bringing a a mixture of both
and he's really making the players
really think about their defensive
options just opening them up
plays that solid neutral and then once
he gets in on you it can be a nightmare
so
really solid first uh first victory up
on the board there for him and he's
gonna advance
into the next match with a 1-0 lead
that's massive
yeah i think the way he's playing anchor
is just insanely impressive right he's
kind of like dark dark hit rises right
he's got so much bar that he knows if i
touch you i'm just gonna shotgun you and
you're dead that character's gone and
then as long as i've got something for
some uh ex kicks some of ronaldinho's
i'm i'm blessed and that's how he's
played it
all got hit there
with the flip just jump the flips bro
easy peasy right oh no combo
yeah
oh
good blocks though didn't get the rejun
but does have the defense
tetris time
okay stuff there the plus frames there
the defend old back dash was caught and
look full combo time oh that was so sick
was that jump s
i think so yeah jump s and then you got
follow up that was sick
yeah that was a
oh my every time tyra every time
untickable
untickable and she gets a ton of bar in
that situation big bang come and have a
hard time
backing off just in case
of a follow-up oh my goodness
oh man
always ready man always ready look at
this
okay
spark up there pepe not feeling it just
realizing that 17 was in danger here we
go
yep i like that extension with the uh ui
assist
he just built
you kidding me
he's a ranger man he's out here
oh my goodness gp paying off
he's just going to get himself a good
knockdown situation here
jump the r that was a good option
because now you're going to get this
follow-up let's go
and yeah he's got hit on point something
we haven't seen too many times
uh this tournament can 70 get out just
reflect again what do you see how
delayed that was and he's definitely
gonna snap in 17 again
100 bring 17 back yes
oh he was reaching with the 2h
whoa he calls confirmed are you seeing
this he's like he got the hit he wasn't
sure if it was going to confirm or not
so he waited and then he still did it
fantastic stuff man that was really
really clean
yeah yeah for sure you can see the
delays so you know he's hit confirming
right it's
so calculated this is like
the xp that you can't really learn you
just have to be playing this cancer for
such a long time to understand and feel
out i think
absolutely absolutely well said
okay
staircases
okay uses the the guard cancel vanish
there
yeah try to do h that's not how you do
with that button unfortunately
and here we go level three maybe
oh no we can one one one right
not enough to kill though yeah realizes
that mid combo and just doesn't do the
follow up because essentially he might
have been wasting bar there um true so
let's see okay here we go let's play now
with the dragon rush
okay and he's gonna go straight for the
level three there and ui level three of
course does track so that's a good
option
get some good damage up here but now
let's see what the follow-up's gonna be
be
coherent it's down to the cohen to try
and block successfully
the reflect more windy reflects bro
i didn't say it man the biggest killer
in dragon ball z is guess reflect god be
careful with that man
it's very tempted to do right but yeah
you've got to sometimes light a bullet
and firm the pressure
right now though
pepe try to kind of make this comeback
right yeah let's see i mean level three
this this can definitely happen um let's
see how this one unfolds
it's definitely going to be a uh
different situation but look it's it's
econ's hit it's just been so good it's
hard to bet against him you know
mm-hmm
okay the laser there six and the dr oh
my goodness getting hit by all the stuff
there we go never mind it's all up to
blue blue jeter now
yeah we've not seen we've not seen hit
get taken down in quite a while i think
that in a few matches to be fair
okay yep and again man look kojia blue
definitely some of the um
some of the better super dash confirms
in the game like you know you can always
get that smash effect follow up you can
bring you uh across the screen fairly
easily i look going
straight away look looking pretty even
in bar and in uh health here so let's
see
he's out oh
wait wait can he kill
oh my goodness
uh i don't know
i don't know if he's limit break
limit break maybe level i don't think so
yeah i don't think so either it's it's
going to be a pixel but the i think the
mix is pretty potent does he grab strike
he's got so many options right
oh wait
did the vanish follow up okay oh great
take that was critical right there three
cohen
oh my goodness yo the last second
dash
into the l and man he's gonna get that
kill 2-0 and that could have gone either
way bro that was looking good that was
looking super clutch that could have
gone either way
yeah 100 i think uh
pepe was probably feeling a little bit
good getting rid of hit
maybe slightly under mis underestimate
the gogeta uh had to show respect to
right because we've seen the gogeta dp
be very impactful in the match so
i understand the respect but yeah just
jumped away came back in just very fluid
movement from uh ikoyan and that's why
he's won so many matches back to back so
they make sense and if he wins one more
um game he he's made it all the way from
losing the first game of the tournament
all the way to the grand finals but he
needs to get one more up on the board
guys pepe not gonna be making it easy
for him let's see
how our losers finals uh unfolds here
it's been a really really fun tournament
but man uh unfortunately one of these
guys has to go home
let's see
we can see who that's going to be right
now okay cs is there
oh my goodness that you know that's a
100 percent hit ratio c4 yeah it's not
missed
yep like guaranteed it's pretty much
unseeable because you're thinking about
you know kefla is he going to be there
the overhead is she going to go low
larry or what she's going to do and then
she's thrown in a left right mix now and
it's just oh scary
yeah nice super opponent i don't know
how it's allowed to be done
yeah it's kind of cheap man this is
pretty
it's unseeable right oh no the stop i'm
getting vertigo we're too high in the
sky tiring yeah bring it back down seven
thank you thank you yeah i was getting a
bit yeah for sure
the frequent flyer miles were definitely
going up
um okay
oh man
grounded with the five-o challenge
and now he cohen's the one
doing what
again
it always seems to fall in ikoyian's
like favor somehow someway he makes it
work
with his orthodox team backs away let's
say he jumped out the corner you might
regret this because he's going to build
a ton of bar as you've seen throughout
this tournament here we go
yeah knock down one
into potentially level three let's see
no oh yeah there okay there we go go
tanks
okay
just i guess just trying to get as much
up there on on hit as possible right
because here has been the character man
like that's been the one you want to
bring down
oh spark up okay
and
oh yeah i didn't want to take the legs
you got two
oh no not like this and look at the
extension android 17 goes down and go
tanks is going to take that damage as
well oh my goodness the confirm as well
off the dp assist
eco and everything falling his way after
that happy birthday man
bro auto combo
damn
let it rip oh the super dash does catch
though just before the c assist from hit
could
come out oh mr dragon rush and super
dash and assist again
we have found
ultimate neutral yeah that's that's how
you do it man look at this and he going
with three extremely healthy characters
going up to going up against uh
[Applause]
one ui boy
let's find out how this goes
yeah let's see right now
oh man
i think yeah you got two he's got one
assist on deck he's got more than enough
bar
unfortunately
some people say you guys paid to win but
yeah today
that 499 did not
secure the win for pepe he does go down
to the
the hero of the tournament losers run
kyan
um yo he has made quite a run for sure
and now that yo that was his so he lost
the first game
he has then proceeded to win eight games
in a row
guys eight game that was his eighth win
in a row in losers bracket that's just
nuts
um and with that one he advances on to
the grand finals of the tournament where
he's going to get a match against
kuzumotsu um but let's just have a quick
look at some of the action that just
unfolded man because that was some super
impressive play man with this draggable
super lineup
kefla gogeta blue hit and the hit is
really the character that just has been
standing out to me glaring uh menacingly
was
really looking dominant really really
good stuff yeah he's uh he's focused
that's why he's frowning right he is
he's there for a job and that's to clean
up shop i think he lost him one game uh
in that set
and
i think ogier cleaned up teddy king he
came into the extra shift and uh yeah
finished it right but uh yeah i think
hit is one of those characters again
when we talk about the the teams that
we've seen today
he's unique like he's the character
where you stand block and react to the
low where a lot of other characters you
do it the other way around right so he
can send you for a loop if you're not
ready for him and
uh to be fair
i don't even think it's just that
the neutrals has been immaculate yeah
immaculate
yeah the neutral has been super super
good and he's really been making good
usage of that um
more neutral play style that you can
play in this season of the game right
you know um and we can just have a quick
look at the bracket here how it's
unfolded um man cohen has done a super
super heroic run
advancing through his through through
his matches and he moves into the grand
finals where he's gonna get the game
against kuzumotsu playing that super
super snowball esque
go tanks team you know all about that
momentum if he gets that hit you know it
could be curtains for your entire lineup
so
let's see how this one unfolds because i
feel like econ is playing a similar
style here with kefla he gets the hit in
neutral utilizing those great assists uh
the good assist calls and the movement
options that kefla has you know the same
way that kuzumotsu has been using that
with gotenks um you know and it's the
same thing he's been knocking him down
bringing to the corner sets up the uh
the ray zone the same way that the kuzu
monster's been set on the ghost so it's
a battle of the same playstyle honestly
and it's gonna be going down here guys
we're in the grand final right now we're
gonna get this action for you in just a
moment but man it's been a great one
today and thank you all so much for
joining us let's go guys it's grand
final time
let's get into it let's go i'm ready
like i said i'm ready
the battle of the play styles the battle
of wheels right because they're both
going for the same thing ikoyan is just
uh in losers obviously so he's gonna
have to
do it twice
once it's nice but you've got to do it
twice right when you're coming from
losers because the muto has has kind of
been called off right maybe the hands
are a little bit cold
but we've seen
the gameplay we've seen the strat very
strong very consistent and because mutsu
can pull it off perfectly even without
one of these characters intact so
oh my goodness look both players
immediately trying to get that hit but
it is
who gets the first hit and he's going to
shout cancel his way towards the corner
look at this you have no assists to get
the dr knocked down unfortunately so he
would not be able to get ghost okay in
that situation
pre-sparked 2m start damage and the
meter build
okay knocked down
he's in here
who's who might even spark you know like
you cohen's already spent his spark and
he might die on the next touch so i
think a pretty important part
yes reflect again tyrant guess reflect
i'm telling you
gonna die there because of it bro
the fear is too strong
the fear is true strong and i think if
uh ikoyon had si assist ready when he
had that uh
spark hit i think he could have killed
but yeah 17
sorry hit didn't come back in time the
air confirmed
on point
and look at this
oh my goodness
yeah snap her in man that's 50 of her
damage just gone oh that was such a
dirty flow as well after the snap oh my
gosh the movement this hit
this hit he's getting grabbed so uh 21
during the superiority your your base
roster i'm dlc people have to work for
me now we're gonna eat this krispy kreme
and get a mix
okay let's see what's gonna be here
in front that time
okay oh my goodness the tap dr pays off
for zumatsu right now cooking with one
of the best characters in the game 21
gonna get that knocked down yeah was
unable to kill there
what a turnaround man he said i don't
care about having birthdays now i'm just
playing the game out here okay there we
go
and this is really good for uh
i mean he's still got he's got another
navigate around the spark that he's on
christmas side
this is solo
gotex not the strongest but i mean with
spark with five bars we can get some
stuff done
seven dragon balls on the table as well
could be a a wish in the future
possession let's find out like this mix
though i know you're gonna have to deal
with this first of course i mean he
could do it for sure he could spark up
let's find out there it is oh man
okay
he vanished there
i just get in oh there it is
the damage is going to be hugely for i'm
not sure about killing but
it's going to be some great damage okay
goes for the ghost loki
it's green as well double reflected
but that clashing to 2h was actually
ridiculous
oh they're hit as well and he's gonna go
for the full six s combo into the shout
cancel bro kuzumatsu he's cooking right
now go so okay on the way here we go
start it up
oh
oh man oh man so scary oh my god okay
vanished
use the glide cancel vanish there yeah
good option
went too fast to do it
no matter how much bar you spend go
tanks hunting you down kuzumatsu firing
back after the calvin looks so strong at
the start our first game wow
you know what
yeah that was super sick he he believed
put his heart
in the cards and and the miracles worked
miracle punches literally skidaddles to
doodle i control the neutral that's all
he did and it was so calculated
yeah it was it was so good man like
it off like maintaining composure after
a happy birthday as well where like you
know the guy obviously he sees that you
know you're taking like 50 damage on
your next character snaps you in
like to maintain okay right boom just
just keep focus i need to just maintain
my composure because i'm actually doing
it and you're seeing why he's hitting
the winner's side of the grand finals
man he cohen might have done that run
through the losers bracket but this guy
didn't even get sent there in the first
place
wow
yeah
i mean that first round is definitely a
good indication of what we're
this set's about right this is going to
be
extremely
extremely sweet uh
200 points to the winner 152 ever
becomes second but like you said
rags to riches story kyan i'm sure he's
got a lot of fans in the chat that wants
to see him succeed but because he mutsu
being an actual
final rainbos trying to kill dreams here
man look at the set
play
i love it man i love in the go tanks
optimization man every single hit and
he's going to go for the double region
of course a lot more scaling than there
once was but still in a good situation
he's looking unstoppable bro
bro he was so sick he had the bar to do
it before anyway i think you want to
burst
you on a spark oh did you dash up the
flex that shot reflects
yeah that was not a good reflect and
look at the damage kuzumatsu is just on
fire with this unique go tanks on point
t
man
oh my god the shield
had the protection
oh oh oh okay okay he could all go
downhill real quick right now
gogeta of the blue variety does get the
hit two bars on deck brings in hit
the main stage powerhouses in the
building your legs prep check foot
locker said they've got your trainers in
store
so much damage
got them
here we go oh man okay here we go
oh no no no no no it's not looking good
right now
okay doesn't bro i'll tell you what man
i'm trying to kill go tanks as soon as
possible like this this character i
would i would have snapped him in i'm
not gonna lie like
but right now is he counting with the
hit look at this gonna get the kill on
android 21.
look at that one bar spend now
wow so worth it let's go yep yep all
from a 2m as well just stepping on the
crips next time we get some velcro
trainers instead of laces bro because if
you can't tie your laces you can't check
your toes when it's on screen you're
going to lose a character real quick
totally totally
okay oh man there we go shout out
shout it out bro boom beam into the
follow up here boner shout cancel there
be with the spark up they actually did
he actually got the hit but no
conversion unfortunately
look at this movement right now oh stay
mobile all the h
that was rapido time i did not see it
bro that h of course moves him forward
so far that's going to be a dead go
tanks yep two bar spend
wow
here we go it's all up to the super
saiyan 2. i mean tingo on solo not you
can definitely do this man he's not
terrible on his own
yeah definitely definitely can oh and
this is a very good start because when
he gets the hit he gets mad damage he
gets mad me i mean he always
always gets the corner somehow i know i
know i know always brings you to the
corner man
[Music]
okay oh no conversion there that could
be a critical error right there for me
oh my god goodness bro it's never a bad
time to do that let me tell you
it's always yeah
completely completely avoided the uh
236 hate from er from tolhan there oh
yeah blocked the unblockable title oh no
he went for them vanished he referenced
he went for the guy council there
i didn't pay off oh no this is the
follow-up the car went in trouble
just do it super dash bro it's the best
got nothing to lose right dead character
yep this dungeon doesn't drop
yeah
i kind of like going for level three
there that was a curious situation to go
for a level one even though tolkien has
a really damaging one yeah you've got
you've got to make sure all right i'm
i'm pretty sure that even even with his
level one i don't know if that would
have killed man just get that kill it's
so important at this stage okay
oh my god
oh my goodness
absolutely moving oh my goodness this is
gonna get the kill
t gohan the super saiyan two
oh no
chosen one
hold on
yeah do it now go on do it now
oh man for the birds
yeah
oh
that was creepy
that was that was proper cheeky as well
that was neutral the timing on that
5m
was was exquisite oh man man slipped on
the ice bro
no no
did not put the sign out gohan didn't
see it coming bro boom it's over
1-1 now and this is still the first set
of grand finals guys so
i mean
uh kuzumotsu needs to win two more and
the whole tournament is his bro but he
can't gonna have to make really run that
he bro he's gonna have to tap into the
special reserves because man he's gotta
be running out of steam by now he has he
lost once again guys to reiterate
carlin has lost
he lost in this tournament he lost the
first game and they made the entire
losers run
he won eight games in a row and loses
bracket and now he's here in the grand
finals to take on kuzumasu um
so bro at what point does the stamina
start to run out because yeah it's a
real factor man like yeah we've been
there in tournament you know
both of us have
you start to get to a point where you
just feel exhausted you know yeah yeah
mentally physically we've said this
before right you're 100 on point with
this i mean and the worst thing is
because you've done this run from losers
there's no zenkai boost because you
can't lose anymore there's no like
they're turning stronger right so i
don't know if someone in the chat wants
to start throwing some sensory beans he
might need it because because mutsuo is
just taking it to him and we're gonna
see
this this is deja vu dave plus one we've
seen this before it's so potent the
spark to get out of it though
go tanks still very very scary this
version of the game
okay there we go two one four s into the
follow up gets a corner position and
with that the ghost again and look let's
assist cool down
it's just such a good strategy yeah oh
my goodness
can't clash with that
unfortunately didn't get the assistant
time to get follow-up
but he come on does however get the dr
and now look at this situation
gonna get knocked down
there to take out the super dash
yeah oh my gosh big fist and he just
fights back oh the challenge
this is what happens when you come from
losers man you've literally got nothing
to lose you are swinging for your life
and he's going to get rewarded with a
with a dead saying audi's being caught
and incomes hit the man of the hour
absolutely because he wants to now it's
down to the team gohan andrew 21 shell
we saw he can do work with them but man
without that go tanks really just you
know streamlining the team and you know
really just allowing that momentum to
happen oh my goodness you've got to take
risks like that the dragon punch did not
work out and he going should be able to
get a kill here on gohan
look at that man nobody needed
yeah like
the spacing the awareness the the dp
making sure not to block it
just
everything everything about the current
uh hit
is just
insanity he is so crisp with this
character it is all falling into place
right now but kuzumotsu does get a good
combo gonna go for a re-jump and the
damage is going to be huge here that was
a medium starter guys
there we go android 21
gonna get the level three off here we go
more
not only a good option you know she does
get his little bear life back she gets
the good oaky on there
the stocks it's all good for 21.
oh my gaze did you see the reaction
we forgot man we forgot because we've
been
watching eq on to like run we forgot
about because mutual's like in reactions
yeah ready with those that two weeks
that was super super good
okay
again look at this now just pepper in
full screen with the fire balls oh my
goodness
didn't get the notes
yeah stardust into the level one and
that's it right there the car one man
he's looking to reset the bracket he
needs one more it's 2-1 currently but
kuzumotsu is it falling away from him
who knows man
and when that uh when that torpedo hits
it's gonna feel like you're getting hit
by a ton of bricks but the damage is
outrageous when god got uh gaugier hit
you with that absolutely mad yeah gogia
is definitely one of the harder hitting
characters in the game it's like a lot
of people thought that you know maybe
not so strong because it's kind of hard
for him to get that initial hit
but bro like the the distance that it
covers and they they buff the startup as
well so so it's actually pretty quick
now um it's scary for sure yeah yeah i
think that's something that uh icon's
like really shown that they're really
good at the spacing when suppressed
buttons yeah obviously he's got the
really strong wicks with kefla and the
dp but
like kefla and the other two characters
do really need to be in specific spaces
to utilize the buttons really well
absolutely absolutely um so here we go
guys we are moving in to the fourth
match
of the first set of grand finals here
at the dragonball fighters world
championship tenkaichi masters
event japan edition
man kuzumaswa for a fantastic start here
and i feel like he always starts off so
strong with this go tanks man
yeah i mean and this the ghostbusters
time oh my and kefla literally said i'm
not afraid of no go she you download the
way out of the corner and that's such a
sick option that is only available to
kefla yeah that 214 s that
commands uh command dash gets her out
but look at this and cohen just going to
work
that's going to be a dead go tanks and
listen you take down that character
you're taking down a big piece of the
puzzle but oh no he dropped it what
happened
don't let him live
okay both are assisted down so no raw
tag is available here
on vanish
available and this is where he cohen
gets his chance oh doesn't matter
he had to resort to the raw taxi for he
had to do it man yeah yeah yeah it was
getting real squeaky hours right now
it's to confirm though gogeta
and look at the momentum from it
right now he's on the defense
tetris time maybe oh no he gets hit
instead
medium
spin they're gonna get the knock down
okay oh my goodness look at this wow
yeah good blocks
oh man he sparked up he realized he
realized he's like yeah you know what
i'm not not liking this about blue life
gotta turn this around
yeah look at the damage he's getting
yeah this is pretty spark2m i'm i was
thinking is he dead but
oh well he would have been close he got
that a little bit of extra bar i think
that was probably dead i think so too
i'm with you i was about to say like if
he gets the never bar here
he his name could be in the death knight
could be in the death note
oh the challenge though from kazumatsu
auto combo
oh my goodness look at this damage you
wanna talk about damage man we gotta
talk about team guard for a second and
talking of dead characters i think
that's gonna do it right there
oh no
just didn't get the extra bit of bar i
think one one three would have killed
same side good blocks 6m i take it back
shaz class charts curse once again
they were good blocks
plummer is in the building getting rid
of the blockages 6m hits ice confirmed
with 21.
but the punish on the reflect attempt
kuzumotsu turn things around i don't
know what happened something changed
right here
he just switched things up right there
was so impressive kuzumasu should be
able to get the kill here on this gojira
blue and in comes hit by bro once
cohen's hit comes in that's when the
game starts
100 that's it this is this is what
maybe econ's been waiting for he's like
yep
three one i've got this hands up
here we go guys
let's go first character you've got to
take down is android 21. it's going to
be difficult from the situation though
with no bar even if he gets the hit okay
doesn't matter the second hit yeah there
was no uh meter penalty in effect there
we go
doesn't matter got enough damage there
to get the kill
okay two characters for kazumasu but man
cohen
oh the spin hit the other side
oh man
yo
he's got his own back he doesn't need
any goons to help him out
here we go dragon rush probably going to
send into yeah when there's something
strange in neighborhoods
oh he got a hit but again i don't think
this is going to be able to kill
yeah
if he's going to get a d i end up so
he's going to run it back he's going to
deja vu
yeah he is indeed he's just going to
keep doing this rinse and repeat keep it
meaty with the ghost force hit into a
situation where he's gonna have to
defend but oh the super dash works out
oh my goodness joey cohen almost dropped
it there
but using that last second vanish to uh
clutch out but man listen team gohan in
neutral there's so many approaching
options people think about right now of
course the super dash of course
kuzumatsu should be able to get this
kill and he does so there we go guys two
two first set of grand finals are we
going to get a reset or is kuzumasu
gonna run away with the tournament let's
find out next game
determines the fate of this bracket
yep yep and i think this is the closest
uh someone come to be in uh kazumitsu i
feel like he's been on the back seat a
lot of the rounds and he's just managed
to clutch out but it is 2-2 it is 2-2
i can't call it man it's pretty close
we've had the back and forth we've seen
the escapes the the thing that basically
got uh kazumoto to the finals was the
ghost oaky and kefir just went
what like do you not know what i do
exactly exactly
cohen really has just put a stop to that
game plan it feels like once he gets
going it just looks real real rough man
like both players
really do use a very momentum based play
style it feels like once they get moving
it's it's we've said this time time
again right it's just that snowball
effect but can he continue that into the
grand finals
reset bracket but he needs to get this
one up on the board here because he must
be not going to make it easy gets the
hit
first opening gambit goes because matsu
and look at this
214m here follow-up time ghost oaky
gonna let those assists recover
and this is where it goes okay so
effective look at this
oh what happens
yeah i'm not sure what that was for but
you know what we take those because
korean gets the hit this is potentially
his last game he needs to win this to
reset the bracket a little bit of
reprieve oh you've got two no
one left
out and that could be
seriously um that could that could be a
critical moment right that'd be a
critical error for economic i think he
is going to be able to kill go tanks
here
but of course you know not getting gohan
there was a was a big um
was it a big fault on that spot but
doesn't matter you know still killing
goatings that's still very important
yeah yeah i agree i think they might
have been enabled to kill without a
spark but obviously sparking because
they saw the tall hunting it was you
know what happened there
i mean
kellyanne's still going in he's trying
not to uh later phase him he's keeping
his mind on the prize
continuing this uh his beat down
absolutely i mean the other day he still
did kill a character and you know he got
the hit initially on gohan so no things
really working out for him regardless
there we go look at this situation for
himself this is really really good kefla
going to work
knocked down time he sets up his own
ghost oaky almost
backs off
yep see assist look down again it's
telling you that assist
absolutely boxed up jaw has been spun
like this mixed with the c assist from
here all it does is so simple and
effective like you jump you get locked
down now you have to guess on the ground
i'll be there waiting for you just like
a good friend in toy story now put him
in the two hates that was so sick yeah
man because he must be not doing the
help i think i'm not sure what he tried
there if he did try the hell vanish
didn't work out but man everything's
just working out
guys we couldn't move towards a reset
bracket if if cohen can win this win
this match here
it's all up to team gohan
is
i mean
he's got the damage but he's basically
gotta kill a full squad
[Music]
pretty much and all he blocks the cross
under mix but not the id
wait a second
you can't with a just an almost
insurmountable life leader looks like
[ __ ]
you do not count them out guys
that was low that time all right here we
go
okay hit so hard but man he's gonna have
to he's gonna have to try and get
another hit right after this
chase down on the uptake
a lot to see us takes him with but you
know what doesn't work he's gonna do it
yeah
cohen i think he's done it c4 yes he has
reset the bracket guys we are going to
go to another set of grands finals
let's go e cohen just looking so
dominant man he doesn't want this to end
bro he wants more games he's already
that's his ninth set in a row that he's
won
out the losers bracket like
after losing the like after losing the
first
this is he he's made the longest
possible run you could make in a
tournament he's lost the first game and
then he's gone all the way now to reset
the bracket
all the way through to grand finals
and we're gonna get more games so
let's see how this one unfolds guys
yep yep shin final set this is gonna be
insane because it was close it was free
too right
and i think because the mutsu must be
thinking are you ever going to run out
of steam what's going on all you doing
is playing back to back this is i
thought it was in the dragon ball fire
stream this is literally eq on the
stream like it's just game after game of
him winning right it's just a showcase
of uh his team
um yeah he does not want this to end man
he does not want to uh go down with
anything less than first place and
that's how it should be man if you're
only in these tournaments you should be
there to win andy cohen is looking like
he is ready to do so but kazumasu needs
to
that needs to turn this around man like
it's all about who gets the first hit i
feel like you know
that's what it really boils down to and
right there you see cohen that gets the
dragon rush to start things off let's go
yeah got no assist though so i don't
know how he's going to keep the momentum
let's find out probably falling heavy
and yeah
oh
oh
man
[Applause]
the challenge right there he going this
kepler just doesn't want to quit
yeah
oh that was sick yeah i like that chase
down with this viable
no
you know what
that super dash hit center there was no
chance of blocking that right that was
so hard to see
and look all that spark time got wasted
on kuzumotsu's side
reflect raw tag bro that's the that's
the true strategy right there
that is a definitely a very strong way
to get out of that mix
up back yep and there we go again with
the dash dp but tolhan already escaped
said i gotta go home and do some school
work i promised gg
but back to fighting now oh my goodness
looking so good right now here we go
knock down time
spark up though
yeah i see you
wow and look into my eyes the dp hits
both oh that was so smart cp raw a dp z
change right there and now he's gonna
stop the ghosts
oh my goodness yeah i love i love how
because because he wants to dash is like
under the ghosts as well
in that situation just in case of a
vanish and it paid off here we go
bro this is sick because he pulled him
out the corner slightly as well yeah but
the beyblade i saw that yeah that was
really sick all cupcakes same side wow
i mean i wasn't ready for it
it's a tough one for sure man here we go
see assist in there as well jump the r
into the hit level three
all right hands are up no sparkling
decks you're gonna have to block this
honestly watch out the floor might be
laugh off
oh my goodness no chef let assist
lockston into the iad and now he cohen
gonna be able to get the kill here on
android 21.
team gohan coming in bro it's a lot to
these uh
the young saiyans now mm-hmm
yeah the uh rats that cook brad eat
stuff
the floor is lava
all right
slipping on that ice for a second
okay pressuring away
all right there we go get yourself out
the corner girl cancel vanish and now
the pressure once again
px kicks
bombos oh there we go
yeah gonna be decent damage and
more
important than that it's time for the
set play oh goes low
yeah
and he got that he's going to be able to
okay yeah it did not have an assist
available and there's a bit of a bit of
an awkward height there to go for a
re-jump so
everything working out anyway because he
must be able to make that happen got the
kill on here good stuff
crazy stuff nice dirt
wow and snuffed out kefla just before
the dp assist came out
very lucky if i must say so kazoo
mozzo's gonna take it though and here we
go all
goes on screen
yeah
empty low and there we go unfortunately
that ghost missed but i don't think he's
gonna need it um should be able to get
this kill into level one and then into
gohan level one and that's going to be
kefla out of the picture
nogina blue gonna come in three cohen
gonna have to mop up but it's not gonna
be easy
[Music]
yeah time for the clean up through to
enter the building normally it's hit but
we've seen gojira do it before on go
inside how the 2m gets jumped away from
big buttons here
we go
back as well
hey oh god thinks the assist is actually
really underrated man it's so good
oh yeah 100 i definitely agree
yeah
oh
man wow
that looked really far from me man i
don't know what
because
you press the button or what but
man that
grounded button hit from so far away and
now we're going down both characters
with less than half life
yeah two fusions 500 sun fusions yeah
right oh that's gonna be a super dash
chase yeah that's gonna be massive right
there
should be able to get the extension and
get the kill yeah he's going to go into
dynamite kick yeah dead
what
what a gamble right there for a cowan
like yeah to play that solid the whole
time and then to just gamble it on on a
level three like that i don't know man
yeah
it was a weird situation right because
there was nothing really happening uh
like because it must have just jumped
and the level three came out i'm not
under maybe he was like an input error
or he falls in a super dash like we've
seen a lot of jump forward super dashes
maybe yeah maybe he was just trying to
maybe just trying to like really call
him out for it but that does sound quite
weird i mean it could have been
execution error maybe he did like went
for the dp which is a 2-1 input as well
or yeah maybe accidentally got the i
don't know like it could have been a
number of things but
um regardless that's going to be a win
on the board for kuzumotsu as we start
things off here cohen gonna have to
rethink uh i mean i i wouldn't even say
rethink the strategy because he's been
playing really really well like
it's he's been going so close and he
obviously reset the bracket um i feel
like if he just maintains his composure
and plays his game
things could go his way um so let's see
how this one goes
yeah no no doubt man like each game has
been pretty close as well going down to
like last character last decision uh
clutch moments and he's been dealing
with the ghost loki fairly well and
there we go with the brexit reflect into
golgi and now we're going to get the
party started
the damage watch
massive right there
look at this now
man he cohen turning things around and
this is this is really really good to
see man he's not thinking about that
previous game he's just he's just doing
exactly
what we spoke about and he's just
playing his game
um okay kuzumatsu though
spark is gone oh my goodness i don't
know that was wild man inviting from
there
[Music]
because it's not laying up right any
opportunity oh yes reflect once again
i'm not gonna get a kill
yeah he's dead man oh he dropped the
combo he would have definitely killed
though oh my goodness wow
bro oh saved himself a ton of me
yeah that was uh that was
financial decisions very smart financial
decisions
okay
that was sick
man spaced out the dive kick and then
just boom thrown out the dp oh look at
all that blue love going back
oh my goodness
yeah that sick play got a nullified with
that spark and that was a nice combo
route there oh kefla's coming in you
know what this means yeah
yeah level three on the way
manny cavan just looking so good right
now
because zumasu has been unable to get
any kind of momentum really everything
that he's tried has just been counted
successfully
she assists again oh my goodness
[Music]
yeah it's been paving the way that's a
yeah i think that's a brown bread on a
go tanks apart here we go one
one and another one possibly yeah that's
it right there
man team gohan the final uh line of
defense here for kuzumatsu
the calendar is looking so good this
game even the previous game he was
looking really good it was just that
questionable like decision at the end
there you know if that's what he wanted
the level three did not work out but man
like look at this just
maintaining the composure what a
turnaround and with this you should be
able to close this out
yep
bring them down with the kefla and then
with the hit that's gonna seal it
one one now what a turnaround man like
that was
so so impressive
like making the longest possible losers
bracket run
i mean he's at the
the final set of the day
if he can do this that would be just so
impressive and speak volumes man like
really really good
yeah two games away from doing like
things people that there's
stories and fables about these kind of
runs in tournament right someone's he's
gonna have to write an autobiography
like a loser's run
first game just going i had to beat this
player i had to beat this player and
obviously going from first to two to
first to three having to reset the
bracket against someone who's just been
dominating with
such a strong set play with with gotenks
uh yeah i i know there's going to be
plays i want to want to know how to do
this with the team he's playing as well
is it's a it's a triumph for him i feel
even if he can't clutch out to even get
second is is a massive massive
accomplishment absolutely yeah
regardless of what happens now man you
should be you know proud of yourself um
but man that's not what he karen wants
right now he wants to go home with that
dub but kuzumotsu is here to try and
prevent that from happening
let's see how the the final set unfolds
guys
oh 2m
honestly against careful there's so much
to think about and you've got to imagine
right there chris watson was thinking is
he going to go for that that you know
the left right the teleport mix is he
going to go high is he going to go low
there's so much to worry about but the
five ends start and look at the damage
right now
yeah yeah yeah
you spoke about unfolding this guy's
getting origami about he's getting
folded the damage is coming out it's
mental yeah he's getting absolutely
pressured right now but there we go
with the successful team gohan challenge
gets a full combo off
there we go
tanks i mean with that set up the ghost
it's good situation for himself right
now forcing kepler into the defensive
decision the spark is there for you
cohen
yep i love using the goat gear assist to
lock down
i don't know if they wanted that but
worked out all right in the end i guess
okay
oh man
swinging out here going once again guess
the upper hand on the scramble i feel
like that's where he has been so
comfortable
like you know
whenever these two really start
scrapping i feel like cowan is nine
times out of ten coming out on top
yeah i think they have a very good eye
for like close quarter combat like
clearly they they know when to press
buttons when to reflect winter 2h very
strong when it comes to that
all right
nice
[Music]
236 m
into assist super clean
yeah okay nice knock down here okay here
we go skunks rising let's go
i'm gonna get it off here
great situation okie
stores goes behind somehow and great
block oh my goodness
open up tail normally bro
yep tail numbers and that was exposed
man that was polaroid exposure like
the the scene that reflected in bang
with the m all calculated
okay
man
all the van is there to keep it off oh
my goodness it was blocked but the
follow-up
andy cohen is the one that takes
advantage look at this pressuring
because you must've seen the corner what
did maybe wake up nash i'm not sure
but obviously that's gonna be a dead
android 21 it was not a good read
yeah yeah level three there 21 is out
the picture and it's all up to team
gohan and cohen in another fantastic
position
yeah i think the reason has been on
point and it's super scary when
someone's meeting you by eye like
because of the variable wake-up time in
this game you always think i can you
know wake up at this time and then maybe
press a button but nikoi's just got it
on lock what
because it does have tolhan left damage
is definitely
not on the table for them
[Music]
that was that was a shutout right there
man 2h the iad attempts and with that
should be able to get the kill here this
is a lot of damage oh no misses it
yeah it would be a lot of damage if it
hits our
man
that looks that level one does more than
her air one so that's probably why i
went for it
oh
wait a second wait a second
okay he's dead
just have to finish your plate man
father son come and help me huh
yeah let's do it okay okay okay yeah i
didn't want to shout cast to curse it so
yeah good stuff good stuff okay
1v1 i mean equations hit got a bag of
bagamia and health
yeah exactly and they see coins here at
the end of the day you know what i'm
saying
yeah good night
thanks for playing
rough
you're going with a 2-1 lead right now
over kazumatsu just needs one more to
make the legendary run after losing the
first game of losers
dropping into losers after the first
round and then going all the way come on
yeah i mean
you must be on such a high right now
like you've
you've done it at this point right
because you're in the lead you're
technically
winning right yeah even though you lost
the first game you just gotta like
remind yourself just one more just one
more come on then you can you can chill
okay just do one more game you've come
this far you can definitely do this and
he's even got room for error like he's
two one up yeah so you know like
you know even if he's got two chances
here
yeah he's got he's got an extra life
essentially but he needs to win one more
game guys
to get this w and that massive victory
200 points up for grabs for first place
that's massive let's go
yeah yeah i mean clearly well deserving
to both players whoever does get the
first place but ikoyan again like it's a
hero's journey from from losers here
but
i mean this is no joke we've seen uh
because mutsu's defense he's his offense
wow
that was such a good option right there
the projectile and the super dash there
just in case he tries to maybe the
miracle punches to approach
oh my goodness the super dash keep going
and i like that switching the sides
there just to guarantee the corner
go
position
through six s knock down time safe jump
with the neutral
oh he's punching up android 21 oh the dp
assist
that was genius
so big brother
he moved that was coming the guard
cancelled using that dp assist that was
so smart
everything working out yeah yeah this is
a showcase it's ikoyian showcase
i know you was here to see a match but
right now
okay okay fight back dp into tag this is
your moment you're gonna get three bars
you need this momentum because in the
toe you need it and you need this to hit
or at least bait the spark right yeah
that would be huge right there because
because you mostly spark obviously gone
okay eco uncomfortable using it
realizing you know what like his spark's
gone i'm at liberty to use mine at the
end of the day and he's gonna get some
good meter on this one as well
okay
i said ps4 rest mode in 10 minutes but
doesn't look like he's gonna need ten
minutes to take this
yeah
what a 2h and this is going to be a grip
of damage because og are one of the
characters that can bring you back down
to the ground after the 2h and he is
actually brown bread
extra fan with dips and exercise
exercise
all the extras man all the trimmings
that's going to do it cohen looking good
[Music]
man i'm super super good yeah guys 10
minutes rest mo but robbie cohen doesn't
need 10 minutes have you seen how this
guy's playing he'll get this done in two
minutes
okay
[Music]
the h and look at this big live feed
right now there we go kuzumasu able to
finally slow down the pace
now cohen's playing to the beat of his
drum let's go corner situation
ghosts
indeed all right do you look for the raw
tag oh no you see the reflect
i didn't pay it correctly didn't get to
confirm he wanted
that was sick oh my goodness forcing
econ to make a defensive decision and he
did with the guard cancel vanish but he
was ready
to edge the headbutt
yeah yeah and he had to know that was
coming because it's nearly impossible to
do that on reaction because it freezes
time right like a normal vanish very
hard to do on reaction but here we go
tolhan he's in the building
because he mitch is making his comeback
challenge right here
staggering the string though
oh
delaying the super dash on defense is
actually a good option against
characters like ikea because you know it
avoids a number of options a voice to
grab um
you know you'll block it if he tries to
press buttons but here we go kuzu what's
turning this around getting that kill
but look who's coming in it's the man of
the hour cowan's favorite character hit
let's go
yeah yeah and this is just a show
kuzumuku's oh my gosh this is why he's a
shin fodor boss right
[Music]
he's got the boys there the goons lining
up
oh he's not going to get tall on though
so he's gonna have to freestyle the mix
up oh no not like this
oh bro
to do that much work
to do that much work and then he does
wake up hands in the pockets like that's
not good man
oh my gosh
not afraid of no ghosts
236. be afraid you're afraid
he doesn't
he challenged after 6m on hit
yeah you know what he said
live by the sword die by the sword so do
you want to press buttons on here i'll
just press buzzer wake up then we're
just going to give up on all social
constructs out the window
we're done here we're done here
those those last two sequences
were probably the two most disrespectful
things you could have done in this game
man got hit with 6m the dome was blessed
and he wake up he pressed
he was pressing buttons bro he was
present he didn't care he was pressing
buttons he woke up with that as well
straight away after the knock down after
the combo he's like right okay i've got
something for you hold on hold this hold
this yeah yeah oh we just pressing
buttons now yeah is this the game we're
playing yeah and with that guys we are
now moving into the final final final
game of the entire tournament guys it is
reset bracket fifth game
game number five let's get it man i'm
ready for this one it has been such a
explosive event such an interesting uh
range of characters and and player
variety
but it's come down to these two cohen
and kuzumotsu let's go
come on chad who do you think is going
to take it i i can't pull it right 2-2
yeah
even with uh because he must be getting
the first hit we've already seen the
escape with kefla
uh
let's see
you can he goes for it
oh spot
oh wait a minute
okay
oh my goodness the kefla non-stop
the absolute train of offense oh there's
a reset there that might be dead
he delayed it to him and it reset oh
yeah yeah the the light bar's deceiving
us
that's it
yeah done wow
wow
i think they did it on purpose as well
because it was like a it was a delayed
not like a combo delay it was just
purposefully just went oh i'm going to
end randomly here right and and the life
bar like or confused it's like you know
resets in that like it just like doesn't
doesn't display the the true damage you
know so
interesting
okay
okay though trying to make something
happen does still have spark to
absolutely
dominating characters in team gohan and
21. okay oh that was a great option
right there you come with the um
reflect
just to push away any kind of option
spark activated
yeah
we've established that uh ikoyon's like
hit and five l's they come hand in hands
you cannot tame this team gohan bro he
is just swinging
double overhead
this is gonna be
i think that's dead you know yeah
he's he's got the options of level five
if he wants to he's got level one into
three which i think he's gonna go for
because he'll get the stops
yeah level one into
three that's too high yeah way too long
waiting way too long
yeah i was thinking that like you didn't
need to wait that long
yeah i think they were trying to
calculate they could do one one yeah
i think that would have killed as well
actually looking at it yeah i think one
one would you obviously better done it
straight away and they were trying to
calculate on the flight oh no the
calculator betrayed by mathematics and
now
ikayon
looking at that blue hole from here
saying i got you out my dude you're my
guy
bro
i'll tell you what because you loses now
because of that and hit lives
that is one of the worst ways to lose
ever
yeah i mean it's something that i don't
think many people talk about but doing
quick maths on the fly it's hard it's
really hard yeah like
trying to calculate i'm just like oh i
need to save this bar because i've got
two other characters to kill and now
because he's going to when he's the last
character man and some of those dhcs you
know to get the max damage you need to
do like quite strict timing on the
change and stuff so it like it could it
can be like quite annoying to get
sometimes because he wants he's trying
to stay alive guys in the tournament
team gohan gets the hit
i don't think he's going to be able to
get this kill here on kefla
not at all but
it's the
soft knock down which is something backs
away but
okay god cancels in takes care of that
kojita assist right now because he wants
you fighting for his tournament life
trying to stay in the bracket oh my
goodness oh my goodness do it twice
because i'm nice he did it twice because
he's nice double rocket kick
he's still in here man this is tolhan
this is a character that terrorizes
people for
so many months oh but can you get out
challenge oh my goodness he doesn't care
c4 and he's going to get the hit there
cowan could be on the verge of losing
that hit just needs a little bit more
juice
yeah that's it yeah he's done
[Applause]
tyrone you know what they say about kids
with yellow hair they just don't care
he's doing it he's making his comeback
he's so close this is the [ __ ] here we
go guys it had to happen
reset bracket grand finals last
character let's go who you got he cohen
or cuz he wants to guys press one for
each one two for kuzumotsu i want to see
it
oh my gosh there's 200 points on the
line here
oh my gosh
yo
oh my goodness he's fighting back with
gold because he wants him he's not
having it back i'm seeing the love for
he going in the chat oh wait wait oh my
gosh
he's got seven bars i think he's dead
you might even give we're getting level
five
he's gonna give it to us level five oh
my goodness and with that hold that
button econ should be able to close it
out guys he is gonna be your champion
for today oh my goodness there we go
look at this beautiful animation and
with that icarwen has made the longest
possible run you can make
in a fighting game tournament guys he
lost his first match
he lost his first game
and made the complete run winning
10 sets in a row
so impressive that is just astounding
honestly
matt yo
yeah like you said it you summed up
perfectly bro that's yeah but
people
literally
dreaming like so i've we've both been in
tournaments right when you lose a match
and you're like damn it's gonna be so
hard when you use the first match you're
like i guess i'm just a pop monster for
today then right like that's it
equation ran it back reset the bracket
and got to the
most ridiculous clutch moment because it
was 1v1
last game last round last set
and still clutched out so crazy yeah
losing his first game to kakato um and
then just making a just a monster run
through that losers bracket man and
taking it to the absolute limit as well
like does this guy is this guy an
android does he actually run out of
stamina because he was just going
non-stop even those long three out of
five sets he was hanging in there
it was so impressive and doing it with
that unique team as well the dragon ball